this is jaco podcast number 124 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko Willick
good evening echo good evening bullets
punched through the chopper as Nev and I
jumped out together we ran over to the
farthest wounded guy grabbed him ran
back and tossed him into the bird we
picked up a second wounded in action the
same way and then a third amazingly
without becoming casualties ourselves
but by the time everyone was loaded onto
the helicopter there was no room inside
for me I stood on the skids and put on
my helmet so I could tell the pilot to
take off but I found I couldn't talk I
was so dried out my tongue had welded
itself to the roof of my mouth out of
pure fear I had to open my canteen and
drink some water before I could even
gasp let's get this mother out of here
we took the wounded back to base and
returned to the fight without anything
holding him up now I couldn't now
couldn't figure out why Torpy didn't do
something about getting his men
consolidated outside of that paddy he
still kept saying he was pinned down
finally I lost my temper I really chewed
his ass over the radio demanding he'd
get cracking and get those men out of
that paddy now apparently the next thing
he did was put down the radio stand
straight up and begin running from man
to man to get them to move back he got
mowed down right away and died a short
time later maybe I hadn't learned a damn
thing at my con or from Dennis Foley's
near-miss in that minefield I hadn't
asked Torpy to stand up he didn't need
to in order to extricate himself but it
hadn't occurred to me that he would I
had been playing the game as if
lieutenant nap a lot natural
or season leader was in charge it was
due to the force of my word as his
commander that this inexperienced young
lieutenant was sent to his death like
Jim Gardner's Torquay's death was a big
guilt thing for me and has remained so
all my life and that is an excerpt from
the book about face which is by colonel
david hackworth a book that we covered
on this podcast in fact it was the first
book we covered on this podcast and
there is a reason for that the book
about face was and is my favorite book
and when I was deployed to Ramadi in
2006 I read it and reread it every
chance I got
now the book is about war but I have
always found it to be a book about
leadership and in my opinion the best
book I have ever read about leadership
david hackworth who was born and raised
in california lied about his age and
joined the Merchant Marines and served
in the South Pacific at the end of World
War two and then he joined the army
where he rose through the ranks serving
in the Korean War and the Vietnam War
battlefield commissioned an over his
career in combat he was awarded two
Distinguished Service crosses eight
Silver Stars three legions of merit a
Distinguished Flying Cross and eight
Purple Hearts and in the end
he became an outspoken opponent of how
we were fighting the war in Vietnam and
that cost him his career in the army he
went on to write these books and was
able to pass on the lessons that he
learned through these books about face
which as I said we covered on podcast
number two he also wrote a book called
steal my soldier's heart which is
covered on podcast 28 and unfortunately
he died on May 4th 2005 before I ever
got the chance to meet him but a few
months ago someone reached out to me on
social media someone by the name of Jay
Mookie Yama and he was a listener to the
podcast and he he thought I just might
be interested in talking to his father
James Mookie Amma the name looked pretty
familiar I thought I recognized it and I
quickly realized that this was the full
name of one of the men that appeared in
both books about face and steal my
soldier's heart the man Colonel
hackworth simply called Mook then I
replied to Jay and said I would be
absolutely honored to be introduced to
his father who was in fact Major General
James Mookie Amma a retired Army officer
that had served as a company commander
in Vietnam working directly for Colonel
Hackworth and after some logistical
coordination it is my absolute honor to
welcome general James Mookie Yama to the
podcast sir this is an absolute honor
well Jocko it it is the same on this
side I've listened to some of your
podcasts especially the one on steel my
soldiers hearts and I couldn't stop
listening to it
and then I realized I looked at my watch
and I said this is over two hours
already just because of you the way you
picked out the really important things
that happen in fact I've forgotten a lot
of things until you you read verbatim
some of the things that he said and and
he lived what he wrote I might add he
led by example yeah well I definitely
have taken a ton of lessons from him
over the years and that that's why it's
just amazing to be sitting here with you
and let's talk about you though let's
talk about how you ended up in the army
and where you came from and what your
background was you know what once you
take us back to Chicago sure I was born
and raised in the inner city of Chicago
a neighborhood called Logan Square
primarily polish German Italian we were
the only minority family in that
neighborhood and we went to a grammar
school of 900 my brother and I were the
only minorities so I grew up I grew up
basically in a phenomenally white white
environment but I never felt like I was
different really because everybody
treated me fine it was it was a time in
life in the inner city where everybody
knew each other you know in our
neighborhood our block we didn't lock
our doors you know everybody knew that's
the time when you know most mothers
stayed at home and they were the police
of the block if anybody would come by
there was out of order you know they
would take care of it but we we were I'd
say lower middle-class economically we
never owned a home we always lived in an
apartment building my father was an
immigrant from Japan my mother was her
family was from Japan but she was
actually born in Madison Wisconsin and
so my grandparents live with us you know
we all three generations in the same
apartment and
I never felt poor I you know because we
had a strong family our church was only
three blocks away from our apartment
building
every Sunday we put on our Sunday best
clothes and we would walk as a family to
church now it's interesting you you you
said your dad had emigrated from Japan
and your mom was born in Wisconsin yeah
was your mom not didn't your mom get
putting the internment camps with her
family during World War two no no no
here's the thing my father came to the
States in 1918 in fact that was kind of
a funny thing he was he was gonna sign
up for World War one you know which was
still going on but then it ended so he
couldn't he couldn't sign up and and
then when World War two hit he was too
old you know and plus he was a Japanese
he I don't know if you know this or not
Japanese could not become citizens
naturalized citizens of the United
States until 1952 and so so he was a you
know he was still a Japanese citizen but
he was in Chicago my family was in
Chicago my mother and father my brother
I wasn't born I was born during World
War two and so we didn't have to go to
camp mostly the 95% of
japanese-americans at that time or any
one of Japanese descent lived on the
west coast in California Oregon
Washington State Colorado and so when
the war hit Pearl Harbor hit President
Roosevelt signed the executive order
9066 which called for the all people of
Japanese descent to be evacuated from
the west coast and put in concentration
camps in the inner part of the country
basically in deserted desert areas and
these camps they euphemistically refer
to them as relocation centers but they
were really kind my Stan you know your
standard constant
raishin camp with bob warrior fences
with machine guns facing in not out and
people not being able to come and go as
they please a hundred and thirty
thousand people of Japanese descent were
put in these camps and two-thirds of
them were American citizens not aliens
okay and no trials no no the only crime
that they have committed was the that
the color of their skin and their fact
that they were of Japanese descent and
so did your family avoid that because
they were in Chicago yeah there were
only like three or four hundred of us in
Chicago at the time and we weren't
considered a threat but my other the
rest of my family my grandparents on my
mother's side and my cousins and aunts
and uncles they were all in California
and they all got evacuated just imagine
this your it's a Friday night and you
got a knock on your door okay it's the
local FBI agent and he says on Monday
morning be at the corner of Washington
and State Street with two suitcases end
of communication okay and you you know
you don't have time to do hardly
anything and you you know you go there
and then you're put on a train you don't
know where you're going and you wind up
in a camp and you're there for three
years okay so let's say you're your
owner of a small business you lose the
business you no longer have a job right
so you can't pay your mortgage and
things like they lost they lost
everything and now you're 18 let's say
you're 18 years old okay and this
happened to your family right and the
local army recruiter comes that it can't
and says I want you to go die for your
country you know frankly Jocko I don't
know what I would have done I might have
told the guy to take a walk you know or
use other words and yet it's so many of
them joined up and along the the
Italian in the 442nd Regimental Combat
Team that's right and and those guys
fought with incredible bravery and had
some critical battles that turn some de
tied in some critical situations as well
yeah they were the most highly decorated
infantry unit in the history of the
United States Army for its size and time
of service you know and there were a
regimental combat team let's say about
4,500 soldiers because they had an
artillery battalion and other things
they were attached ok in about 18 months
of combat they were awarded over 9,000
purple hearts you know some guys had
three or four you know and if not more
and you know present the Presidential
Unit Citation you're familiar that award
they're our army divisions that never
got that award okay that regimental
combat team was awarded eight
Presidential Unit Citations that's
unbelievable yeah they were my personal
heroes so that's and that was to kind of
get back to your question that was one
of the reasons that that I wanted to
join the army okay I was actually gonna
ask that so you know you're sitting here
saying if you were in one of those camps
you don't know if you might have had to
tell them to go take a walk but when
your time came you you you you walked
into the recruiters office yot away from
it yeah well in my case when I was in
high school as I told you you know faith
is a very strong part of my whole life
I've been so blessed in life beyond
anything I deserve and so when I was our
church you know we go to church every
Sunday I was in the choir I was in Cub
Scouts I was in Boy Scouts I was in the
youth group you know all of this was
centered around the church you know when
I was in scouts I went to the National
Jamboree in Valley Forge Pennsylvania
with 52,000 of my best friends living in
tents and but you know that was and what
was the symbol of that Jamboree George
Washington at Valley Forge
in prayer and the motto of scouting is
for God and country so that was really
my model and then I was in a Boise State
are you familiar with Boise State no
Boise State is an American Legion
program does that so exist yes yeah and
it's it's been around probably for 50
years now when I went it was the 25th
year okay so it's more than 50 years and
the concept of Boise State is they take
junior high school juniors ready to go
into senior year and who are leaders
basically and they form a quasi state
government for two weeks and they
actually divided into two political
parties they don't call them Republicans
and Democrats they call them something
else and and they have state government
County government and local city
government and you run for offices and
you actually have to come up with a
platform and you debate and so it's a
it's a list lesson in civics okay but it
was sponsored by the American Legion so
we all lived in like dorms and the dorms
we had to make our beds so you could
bounce a quarter on it you know and
they're all army blankets stuff and cots
and but it was wonderful it was just a
great experience but so when I was in
high school I but I was very active in
my church in my I'm kind of a German guy
and I was the president of my my high
school youth group at the church and
then I became the vice president of the
Chicago Association where did you play
sports no well I was no I didn't I was
and what about your grades
well I was I was belted in this minor of
my famous school in high school and I
was they have valedictorian in grammar
school yeah that shows you where how
well I did in grammar school I didn't
know that and then I I I was in the band
I played clarinet and saxophone so I was
the first chair clarinet of his a band
that was the principal would win in the
orchestra and so but anyway I was I was
very active in my church youth group and
I I was thinking of becoming a minister
okay but then I was in Junior ROTC
mm-hm and Chicago has the nation's
largest Junior ROTC program about 30
high schools heaven and it's a great
program people misunderstand JROTC they
think it's a feeder for the military
okay I mean some of them do go into the
military but that's not the purpose the
purpose is to give these high school
students something other than gangs to
belong to to give them experience in
leadership and discipline and teamwork
and it's it's a tremendous program so I
was in Junior ROTC was so it's that
combined with your your view of the like
the 442nd those things are kind of
starting to congeal in your head and
maybe move you towards a military yeah
and then in addition to that I have just
one sibling an older brother he's about
7 years older than I am and he joined
the army as an enlisted guy but in the
first year of college he was in a
military fraternity called Pershing
rifles which other people like : Powell
and some others at minute
including myself when I went to the U of
I and that and you have to understand
also that I'm Japanese American in the
Japanese culture the warrior the samurai
is at the top of the social strata okay
unlike China where the scholar was at
the top in Japan it's the warrior so
when I joined the military when I became
a commissioned officer my dad was so
proud you know his small t-shirts
swallowed a large you know
when I became a general it's like you
know incredible but I you know saw so I
want to do ROTC in college as well oh
yes see I'm a driven guy right and and I
was here's here's the thing though as I
told you I was thinking of becoming a
minister but then I also wanted to serve
in the military so what do you think I
would do chaplain pretty much exactly
little problem I'm Protestant and my
denomination theologically went so far
away from what I believed in that I
couldn't buy the theology so now I'm
praying to God right and I'm saying I
get the message I guess you want me to
do my military thing so that's what I
did
okay but you fast forward 50 years 55
years what am i doing today I'm doing
what I wanted to do when I was in high
school because I have military outreach
USA a faith-based nonprofit that I
started so it's a lesson in prayer and
that is at that time I thought God was
telling me no he wasn't telling me no he
was saying wait it's on my schedule not
on your schedule I mean you know I
wasn't mature enough either as as a
military guy nor is in my faith so what
year was it that you're showing up in
college 6161 Darden so you do four years
of college it's 1965 right Vietnam is
really not escalated yet at that point
but did you think it was pretty hot at
that time and I i basically by that time
I I was on the military thing right I
wasn't gonna be a chaplain anymore so I
was I was in Pershing rifles I was under
rifle team I was on the drill team you
know if it smelled military I was in
okay then you have to me remember I had
four years of high school
ROTC also before I went to Benning so
you're pretty good at your drill I think
you know I had
I mean I mean infantry I OBC infantry
officer basic course piece of cake
I mean I I went through that I was an
honor graduate in my class and in fact
this is really funny in my class about
two hundred you know brand-new second
lieutenants right about a third of it
was National Guard and about a third
were reserves and there were only a few
of us that were Regular Army see I got a
distinguished military graduate
commissioned Regular Army infantry right
and so very few of us were Regular Army
in my class so our attitude was not
really the best shall we say and so we
get the Benning and they they marched us
to class I mean this wasn't to us it was
insane we're second lieutenants you know
just tell us where the building is we'll
get there right yeah no we had the March
in formation the army so needless to say
the attitude was not real good right
with my company so the day we graduated
okay
they used to have a award a screamer
that companies could put on their guide
on those called the tiger tactics award
you know this is we're really gung-ho
you know companies and all that which
ours was not needless to say well the
night before we stole from another
company and we put it on our guide on
and so on graduation day we marched by
the headquarters and out comes the
commander the guys livid and you say
where'd you guys get that oh you know
it's just just the beard and we were
graduating then what's the guy gonna do
to us right so we we all graduated and
that was so so 1965 didn't you go to you
went to you went to graduate school yeah
Hereafter yeah here's the thing you know
I told you I had the we we didn't have a
lot of money for me to go to college so
I knew I had to earn it myself
right so when I was in high school my
senior year I worked 33 hours a week I
worked from 5 till 10 o'clock at night
at a warehouse in Chicago and I worked 8
hours on Saturday so I could raise money
ok I also played in two bands I told you
I
please clarinet and saxophone I played
in a Polish band for weddings and that
was so cool because by the third set
everybody was so blessed there's nobody
cared right and then but I also played
in the Jewish band so I used to play for
bar mitzvahs find you all the temples in
Chicago I used to tell people I had them
coming or going either way and then I
had to you know I took out two
government loans and that's the only way
I could afford to go to school and so so
sixty-five rolls around I graduate and I
find this interesting for a for a real
obvious reason you majored in English
yeah College yeah the reason I did that
Jocko is once again you know I'm pretty
focused guy and my my focus was
unbecoming the best officer I could be
the best leader I could be of infantry
soldiers and I knew I was going into
combat right so when as a freshman I
tried to determine what am I gonna major
in to prepare me for that so I looked at
psychology and I looked at English not
rhetoric but English literature okay I
rejected psychology in my first year
because we had these classes classes
with Pavlov and his dogs and all this
stuff you know and I was going through
that and I said what does this have to
do it people you know I mean I'm gonna
learn 100 you know work with people
well literature whether you read the
whole continuum of you know everyman or
Shakespeare or Hemingway if you read
that stuff there are universal traits of
human nature that come out at you okay
if you can understand it you can realize
what motivates people okay so I and then
not only that but if you read the best
writers of all time
I just felt by sher osmosis got not the
smartest guy just by sher osmosis you
know I could absorb that I could express
myself better so that's why I majored in
English and I've talked about I was an
English major as well and I I was I was
I was prior enlisted so I had been in
for eight years and actually I'd been in
for 10 years by the time I went to call
and I knew right away I was gonna be an
English major and the reason I wanted to
be an English major cuz I had I'd gotten
commissioned and served two years in the
in the seals before I went to college as
an officer and I realized you got to
write everything you've got to read
directives from people and got to
understand what they're saying and then
you got to communicate with your troops
and I wanted to have a good command of
the English language the the part that
you talked about the understanding of
human nature was something that I saw
once I got in and I started reading it
so I started applying and thinking about
what I was reading and now this is
something that I that I advocate for
everyone to if you want to really
understand human nature you got to read
yeah yeah so I was so when I was waiting
you know when I said that in 1965 the
war because I think what was it what
year was I drank nineteen that was 1965
wasn't it the battle by doing I think it
was I think I think it was 65 I think it
was and you know they kind of used that
as hey this is when the real escalation
started and and the reason I asked you
that specifically is because I've had
some Vietnam vets on that we're going to
college in 1965 and they were like
they'd even hadn't even heard of Vietnam
at that point so I guess it was because
I was in ROTC you know I was kind of
paying more attention you know and I
knew I was going to bending I mean that
was a foregone conclusion and you knew
you were going to combat as well oh yeah
that was your mind so I yeah because
that was my goal to be an infantry
officer you know and if I did you know
that's that to me was where I wanted to
go and and so in 65 I got an I got an
offer to get an assistantship you know
to to be merely a counselor in the dorm
but it's like I died and went to heaven
because they they paid for tuition and
fees and I got like a hundred bucks a
month salary which to me was like
richest guy in the world but the
important thing was I could get my
master's degree okay and by the way I
got it in a year because I went to
summer school I just I wanted to go on
active duty but this was a chance for me
to go you know under an assistantship
and not having to pay for it but
now the pragmatism kicks in for me you
know because you know really with an
English degree as you know you know it's
it's great for preparing you to
understand things but you know that and
50 cents in those days would get me a
cup of coffee so I and then I knew I was
gonna go into combat I knew I was gonna
be an infantry officer and the odds of
my perhaps getting wounded you know were
fairly decent so I need to have a
fallback you know and I wasn't an
accountant so I wasn't a CPA or you know
something like that
so I got my masters in the teaching of
social studies so I could be a teacher
you know you don't have to run the
hundred yard dash to be a teacher and so
and I'm and teaching is a noble
profession and I always felt that you
know it's something I could do if I got
wounded and still contribute to society
and 70 or you know the seventy-five
percent of your time is an officer or
senior NCO is teaching you know so I
figured I want to find out how the pros
do it allegedly what I found out is the
military has the best education system
really does you know I didn't have to
get my master's degree in history and
philosophy of education and Ed psych and
all that stuff
no didn't need it so you you wrap up you
get your master's degree and now you you
know you're going to Vietnam what what
happens when you graduate
okay so I I go to Fort Bunny I go to I
OBC and you know I'm an undergraduate my
class so I didn't finish that story this
my my my class that I was in you know
really bad attitude guys right and on
the day of graduation they announced the
undergraduates okay I was in the 3rd
platoon so 1st platoon they announced
the undergraduates in the platoon second
platoon they announced the
undergraduates 3rd platoon which I'm in
I'm the only guy who's an undergraduate
out of my platoon when they announced my
name everybody boo because I'm you in
our record right
so what happened is I volunteered for I
volunteered for Eric well I was Regular
Army so I had that I had to go airborne
I volunteered for Ranger School but in
those days the West pointers all it was
mandatory they had to go to Ranger
School so I graduated at the same time
that the West pointers did they took up
all the quotas so I couldn't get into
Ranger school but I had a solution see
I'm always thinking ahead I was gonna I
applied for Pathfinder school mmm-hmm so
I figured I go through Pathfinder school
I'd finish that the West pointers would
be gone I could slide into the next
Ranger class right mm-hmm
they didn't give me dance finder so now
I'm stuck right so I said okay I'm
volunteering from Vietnam and they sent
me in a Korea so I was in the DMZ in
Korea which is really a god thing I've
got to tell you this because I was with
the second ID on the DMZ and those days
you were you were assigned and you
stayed there for 13 months on the DMZ
and there was still active combat
patrolling and we take casualties during
that time 13 months I was there we had
12 K ie about 40 wounded okay so this
was not a walk in the park and it was it
was a great experience for me because in
addition to see we were in the DMZ we
actually had a company compound okay and
we actually had a guard mount you know
and we had our own NCO club and we had
in and so we had all the all the BS of
the admin stuff that you do on when
you're in garrison mm-hmm but we were
doing combat patrolling every day on the
DMZ so it was really a great experience
for me as a young officer because I was
able to lead troops out on patrol but
also I had to do all this admin stuff
you know the garrison and so that was
your platoon commander tour
what were the patrols like what were you
doing basically they were ambushed
patrols because the DMZ was set up where
it was a free fire zone if you saw
anyone you could shoot him because
nobody was supposed to be there okay
and we would have to say
Corian chunky which is they tell him to
stop you know but how many times did you
say that before you pull the trigger
basically but we we did ambush
patrolling primarily and that was you
said you were lucky or you said it was
God that put you there and and do you
feel that because that's just a really
good sort of warm-up for combat
absolutely that's absolutely I feel that
way my first deployment to Iraq was was
relatively it was relatively easy right
we were in Baghdad things were going
pretty well we had the upper hand on the
enemy and we didn't get into too much
major combat you know we got a few
firefights here and there but wasn't
like when I got Ramadi and I felt like
that I was real blessed to have had an
experience where you get the kind of the
initial nervousness out of your system
and you realize okay I can do this that
that was I felt pretty lucky about that
well also you know keep in mind I was I
was just a young second lieutenant
shavetail what did I know really and I
was once again blessed I had a platoon
sergeant who really it was a Korean War
veteran or world you know a guy was
actually an e7 okay and and basically
when I got there you know I was his
lieutenant okay so nobody screwed around
with me but on the other hand I listen
real carefully I mean that's one thing I
learned you know I as a young officer
I've had my success in in the military
because I had great NCOs who made me
look good and I had commanders who
mentored me and didn't cut my head off
when I screwed up and I've made my fair
share of mistakes mm every we all you
get done with that tour and then what's
your what's your next assignment so you
know you get your dream sheet right a
lot where you want to go when you do
roofs when you leave that area and so I
put in for Fort Bragg for Fort Benning
because I wanted to go to an airborne
unit because I was urban but I'd never
served in an airborne unit right they
send me into Fort Lewis Washington
so I go to Fort Lewis Washington to the
the training center infantry training
center ok and when I get there I made a
long story short when I was in Korea I
also was they found out I had a master's
degree so they pulled me off the line
and the battalion commander calls me
into his office right so I go down there
and he says lieutenant Okayama how you
doing sir I'm having a great time you
know I'm I'm with soldiers you know
we're doing combat patrolling you know
and I really and this is what I've been
trained to do you know and any that's
I'm happy okay
so he says I see we have a master's
degree I said yes sir and he said you
know our battalion adjutant is leaving
and you have a degree in English you can
see where this is all going right and I
said yes sir and he said well how would
you like to be the battalion adjutant
and I said sir I'm honored that you
would even consider this but I'm really
happy you know leading soldiers and he
said lieutenant I'm not looking for
happiness in my battalion you will
report on Monday morning you know yes
sir okay so off I went and and I became
the battalion aid unit but that once
again was a great experience for me
because I learned a lot of the admin
stuff in unfortunately and some I also
saw some bad stuff going on which I was
not happy with I saw you know I because
I was the a Jeanette oh and what I
didn't tell you was that was at
battalion level the brigade adjutant
left and they called me up to brigade to
be the brigade now I'm a first
lieutenant
that's a majors position right but I
happen to be pretty good I was the best
battalion dad you know not on all the
Italians so I go up there I go up there
to brigade to be a brigade ad unit and
what I found was
you know the officer efficiency reports
in the Oh ers I knew all the battalion
commanders because I dealt with them all
okay so if if I am mu Yama were to rate
the battalion commanders based on their
leadership right and I would have rated
them one two three four okay mm-hmm but
I saw the reports going through it was
four three two one
and and that's because they were looking
for managers not commanders and so that
was that was a tough pill to swallow so
eye-opening for you as yeah yeah I know
when I worked I was the Admirals aide
and I saw I didn't see stuff like that
that turned me off but I saw just just
getting a better grip on what was
happening behind the scenes was very
important for me and it helped me out
you know later on and when you were in
Fort Lewis that's when you first met
hackworth right absolutely correct this
this was so cool when when you know when
happen on the Campton by this time I'm a
captain right and I met the I'm the
Secretary General of the SDS I was the
secretary the General Staff okay what
that means is I was the assistant for
their chief of staff basically and so I
do you know who Hackworth was focused on
we all we all I mean heck was a legend
you know everybody knew who he was but
also because I had that job one of my
functions was I was the guy who
coordinated the general schedule and the
Chiefs of Staff schedule and Hackworth
was reporting into Fort Lewis as a new
battalion commander okay
well whenever a new battalion commander
came in
I always did research on the person you
know so I could tell the general you
know here's the guy was coming in here's
this background while Harris was you
know mr. infantry basically and so when
he came to see the general he walks into
the headquarters you know I'm sitting
behind this desk he walks in so I stand
up
you know I say welcome Colonel hack
worth to Fort Lewis you know the general
will be with you in ten minutes you know
because he came early right
the first words out of half were smile
I'm not kidding
first words what are you doing sitting
behind the desk he said you should have
a company he said if you want one I'll
give it to you okay
the guy doesn't know me from Adam right
I mean you know and but you know I was
pretty sharp in the way of warming
uniform I did have you know my jump
wings and my I have an expert
infantryman badge okay
and I had my EIB and that's it I didn't
wear any ribbons or hey that stuff and
just the stuff that counted as far as I
was and so hacksaw that you know and and
I said Colonel I really appreciate you
know what you're saying but I came to
the same conclusion that you did a
couple months ago and I've already
talked to a battalion commander who's
accepted me to take one of his companies
so I'm committed to him sir so I can't
you know I'd love to take you up on your
offer but I can't because I committed to
the southern battalion commander and
heck said I understand totally
okay well then turned out to be another
god thing because later on as you know
in the book he and I got together and we
saved the career of a drill sergeant
mm-hmm we I just want to hear a little
bit more about this because it's
something that I haven't been able to
gather from anyone you know in my mind
you know I thought everyone must look at
hack like you know this guy's mr.
infantry as you put it but I also would
say to myself well you know here's the
I'm thinking that because he wrote these
books and because I studied him but that
was an actual thing people knew who he
was by his reputation throughout the
army yeah it was not only his reputation
but his appearance I mean you know his
neck was probably the size of my waist I
mean this you know a hand worth was just
you know he always said you know he
wasn't bald like today you know but you
know Heath of an inch you know razor
sharp you know sides and and all that
and what I didn't say is
he hackers had this unique ability to
size people up when he saw them like
when he said that to me and and I've
said this before but hackers his
philosophy was you're either a dud or a
stud and there was nothing in between
and he had this uncanny I've seen it
dozens of times where he actually did
size guys up and I never saw him this on
that evaluation he just had this this
instinct you know the size guys up and
that's and that's why he was successful
as a commander because one of the
principles is to surround yourself with
good people and so when he came to a
unit he found some guys that weren't
cutting it they were gone
I mean especially in combat you know he
can't tolerate that you know and he
would and he had the strings that he
could pull and he had the relationships
all over the place it seems that's right
now how did when did he leave would to
go to Vietnam and take over the
battalion he probably let the sea I left
in May of 69 so it was probably end of
68 or maybe early 69 and and he goes
over and he's over there for a few
months and then he ends up needing well
he wants to surround himself with good
people again
and so he reaches out to you yeah how
does that happen well you know I was
still at Louis as an AIT company
commander and and another thing I should
tell you at that time I'm not real happy
with the army because they never gave me
any assignment or anything I ever asked
you know you're like oh four four at
this point are you ready for this I I
get what I didn't tell you was in
graduate school I majored in Japanese
history and Chinese history and
political science and Japanese language
in my masters of social studies okay and
I happen to be japanese-american I
haven't have had a tour in Korea right
where by the way I didn't tell you I got
awards from the Korean army and so now
the army comes out with the foreign area
specialty training program or fast okay
and the concept is a great concept you
know in Vietnam he got caught with our
pants down because we don't have any
army experts in Vietnam nobody knew the
culture nobody knew the language the
politics sound familiar
and so basically the army said ok we're
going to develop Geographic experts for
the whole world
ok and we're gonna call it the fast
program so I saw that and it was in the
army time you know they said if you have
an interest called this number you Nolan
so I called you know and he said hey
look pull up my record you know you'll
see you know I got my master's degree in
far recent Affairs ethnically I'm
Japanese I've got a tour in Korea where
I got some awards in the Korean army ok
and I'm Regular Army right what are my
chances getting in this program that it
should be a hundred percent right are
you ready for this the first words out
of their guys mouth
you haven't been to Vietnam and I said
well that's right but if you'll go back
in my record you'll see I volunteered
for Vietnam in the army sent me to Korea
ok he said that doesn't come ok the
second thing he said was you haven't
been the career course Advanced Course
for officers look he got me there I
hadn't you know I was just a young
captain I hadn't been there
so in essence he's telling me you know
come back in a couple of years and maybe
we'll think about it you know he didn't
give me any encouragement he didn't say
hey you're a natural for this program
you know I'll keep on monitoring your
career you know blog he didn't do any of
that stuff and about that time I get the
letter from hackworth saying hey Mukai
we got a war going on if you want a
company it's yours
and like I hit the lotto you know and I
and frankly I was I was sneaking of you
know resigning my Regular Army
Commission but I hadn't been to Vietnam
yet and I was a bachelor
I had a lot of my friends who were
married or going back for their second
and third tours you know and I felt an
obliging underhand course would be the
best opportunity I could I could have so
I jumped at it you know and I'm with it
but things did not come how did you get
orders I mean did you know I know
Hackworth had some relationships with
people but just to get a guy deployed to
be in his battalion how did you how did
he pull that off what did it look like
well I mean I I called my infantry
officer assignment guy whom I never
spoken to him in the five years I was on
active duty right because I always felt
that I shouldn't be managing my own
career you know if I if I did my job
that the army would you know I I'd be
treated okay you know well none of that
ever happened right so I called this guy
at the Pentagon and I say hey I'm
volunteering for Vietnam again and he
basically said well ok you know give me
your phone number in case we lose
connection here and and then he said and
I said but I have a stipulation I need
to go to the 9th division and he said ok
I can make that happen when do you want
to go I said as soon as possible and
this is February and he said oh I can
get you there in August and I said nope
that's not soon enough he said how about
April I said sold so I got orders so you
know now everybody told me in the world
at that time Here I am
infantry Regular Army captain going to
Vietnam when I hit the rep load up oh
they could assign me anywhere you know
and the orders meant nothing you know
because captain's infantry captains were
a dime a dozen so when I get to Vietnam
everything was greased 9th division I
went from the night I went from from
Saigon right to the 9th division at Dawg
camp you know I'd land there I've got my
orders to his battalion it's all obvious
weren't you doing some kind of like
Vietnam and doctor nation for
long and and hack pulled you out two
days into it or so yeah I was so upset
they had a five day in-country training
program for newbies okay especially you
know well you know in the Delta
I'd say 85% of our casualties for from
booby traps and so we were and there was
a special terrain you know with rice
paddies and and canals and you know just
the whole thing was totally different
and so they had this five day training
course to acclimate you and to
understand the booby traps and the
terrain and all this stuff and I'm in it
for two days and I'm pulled out of the
course and I'm put on the helicopter and
they take me down to you know the Potala
and fire support base and I'm madder
than a wet hen you know and I I go to
half and I say sir you know how can you
do this to me I mean I'm trying to learn
how to stay alive you know psyche and he
said MOOC you don't need that stuff I
know you you know yes sir yes sir and
when you showed up so for those of you
that hadn't read haven't read the books
or listen to the other podcasts about
this hacker that showed up but he was
requested by name to go and take over
the 439th in Vietnam which was a problem
which was a battalion that was having a
lot of problems and he went in there and
he fixed it I mean that's there's no
simple way to put it he went in there
and squared that battalion away and made
them from hopeless to hardcore is is the
the terms that get used when you showed
up the he'd already been there for a
while so things were pretty solid at
that point they were they were so good
it was incredible in fact the first guy
I met when I when I got there was our
battalion s4 same as Mario takahashi he
was actually a National Guard guy from
Hawaii he was about six two or six three
bit Japanese you know not like me Saul
was Hackworth could you just you made it
sound when you said that talking about
his neck Lee was he like a big cuz he in
pictures he always looks pretty lean and
and not very physically
well when I I mean is he was stoked okay
I mean he wasn't he wasn't real huge she
wasn't real tall huh
but just the way he carried himself
that's what I always envisioned was he
was just a guy that if you walked away
ago I bet that you know how tall was
Hackworth oh he's 60 yeah find out he's
whatever yeah I understand not only that
but I'll tell you he when I became a
journal later on in life and and he came
to one of my every every year I used to
have a Leadership Conference for my my
officers and my NCOs that I would invite
speakers to come to and hackworth came
to one of my conferences and then he
visited me in Chicago when he was doing
but his about face book right and so he
invited me and my wife and kids to have
dinner with him one night you know he
always said bring your kids you know
some guys would say no just you know
being your wife or whatever because my
kids were fairly young and then weren't
really young different maybe eight or
nine you know at that time and my wife
and the kids actually commented about
how soft-spoken ham birth was he wasn't
a blustery guy you know among guys yeah
but you know in the in public with you
know women and family members he was he
was a gentleman
mm-hmm which kind of surprised my wife
because I told him what about you know
so anybody that's that's how he was and
and so the the battalion when you show
up it's just a the guys are really on
board with what's going on oh absolutely
because I got there probably three weeks
before our famous that it wasn't really
a battle on 22 May where we decimated a
VC training battalion basically and I
mean I remember being at the talk you
know when he's planning while this
Hackworth had this innate quality get
just smell out the enemy
you know even with all the intelligence
we get and all this stuff you know he
was able to figure out what they were
doing and so he set us up for that night
but to answer to you dress what you're
saying by the time I got there Takahashi
was the first guy in that okay he was
really a strong straight shooter and he
was yes four and so he got all the
equipment for the battalion and he got
it whatever way he had to get it you
know and then I meet the next guy I meet
is another as a company commander and
the guy was like six three or something
you know so I'm seeing a pattern here
right now I'm five foot five okay and
but here's the cool thing about this one
of the other company commanders his name
was Don Meyer and by the way hackers had
this really cool way of using words in
terms and titles that you know like our
companies were not alpha Bravo Charlie
Delta they were alert battle claymore
and dagger okay and the Claymore company
commander was a guy by name of Don
Meyers Don Meyers was my roommate in
college at the University of Illinois
and we both were infantry ROTC guys
right and then later he was he was with
the hundred and first then he was
wounded so they shipped them to the
Simmons and then they assigned him to
Fort Lewis which was where Hackworth and
I were so Don and I were roommates again
at Fort Lewis Washington
okay so then half were ships to Vietnam
and he takes Meyers with him okay so now
Meyers who by the way is six foot three
right and his nickname was lank you know
and when he and I were in college as
roommates it was like mutton Jeff you
know and I wasn't that tall guy and so
anyway but as you as you can understand
to have I command a battle company and
he commanded claim our company and I
knew that if we were gonna run into any
cramp you know that he would he would be
there for me
and he knew I would be there for him and
that was that was it just it was really
good yeah that that whole thing with
names is something that I completely
ripped off from hackworth when I was at
asking you to commander our tasking it
was called well there was alpha Bravo
and Charlie and I had Bravo and
immediately when I took it over I
changed the name from Bravo to bruiser
and that's was that changed the attitude
of people it really does well also as
you know all elite units have have
greetings and countersigns right so for
the hardcore or our model was hardcore
we condo that was what the reading was
the countersign which I cannot say
totally was no effing slack okay yeah
but I'll tell you there were a guy I saw
this eye witnesses there were guys were
wounded on stretchers and hackers would
walk up to them and they'd salute him
and say hardcore acondo what kind of
missions did you do when you showed up
there so you take over your company
commander yeah they were they were
problem they were just really Recon
Search Search and Destroy not really
destroy but you know we were we were
seeking out the VC but as it got closer
or two we knew we were leaving right
because President Nixon had had said
that you know so it just got to be you
know recon the area make sure they
weren't there if they were there we get
into firefights but didn't happen very
often those most mostly booby traps and
things and basically that was it
I mean because they had you know they're
smart they knew we were leaving so why
go into I get into contact right leaving
now usually were showing me some
pictures earlier
you're a pretty famous picture that got
published it's someone you're your RTO
had just been wounded what was the story
on that yeah this is one of our
operations and there was a booby trap
and
and he was he got a sucking chest wound
from it and I got a little shrapnel not
a lot and basically I called in a
medevac helicopter and the helicopter
came in unbeknownst to us
there was a UPI photographer on the
helicopter and he snapped a picture of
my guys carrying my wounded RTO on a
stretcher towards the helicopter and
that became like the UPI picture for the
day the one around the world you know
the Vietnam photograph I didn't even
know it existed until three years later
I was out I was off of active duty I was
reading on US News and World Report
magazine and the picture was like three
inches by four inches in the magazine
but it was all my soldiers you know and
I saw it and I said hey and then I saw I
was in the picture so I'm kind of in the
picture so you can see me so I got the
photo from from them I get asked a lot
and it's something that I don't have any
experience worth is what it was like
having draftees as you know I was in
although all-volunteer military and then
on top of that you know the unit I
worked with we were all volunteered
again you know you volunteered to come
in and you volunteer again to try and be
in the SEAL Teams and people asked what
it was like working with draftees now
hack Worth's opinion was draftees were
good because they didn't care about
their career and if they thought
something was wrong they'd say hey this
is crap we don't want to do that or hey
you're not telling the truth to us and
so he thought it was good and it kept
the army in check but there still had to
be some leadership differences in
dealing with and later in your career
obviously you started working with the
all-volunteer army what did you notice
about the draftees that you learned from
well the draftees just like and it
doesn't make any difference for your
draftees or volunteers it depends on the
leadership and you know they'll respond
the good leadership and the the draftees
were like anyone else once you're in the
position you're gonna do the best you
can especially when you're in combat
because you want to survive
and and and by that time it gets to be a
bonding thing you know you're not there
fighting for liberty and justice in the
American Way you're fighting for the guy
to the right of you and the guy to the
left of you basically because you're
going everyday you're living together
you're dying together you know and so
it's it's a function of leadership and
the draftees were great guys
I mean I'd serve with them anywhere in
fact I didn't even know who was straying
I didn't care I didn't ask you know
whether they're draftees our volunteers
although the vast majority of our guys
were draftees in in the 4th of the 39th
mom and and that's what was so cool
about it that hackworth could take that
battalion and turn it around and I heard
stories because I came later on you know
but he had a price on his head
initially yeah a price on his head from
his own guys yeah oh yeah but nobody had
the gonads to step up and clean clean
the price so yeah I mean one of the
things he talks about and again I've
talked about this on another podcast but
you know when he showed up everyone had
whatever they had guitars and they had
radios and they had you know big
hammocks for themselves and and he got
there and said okay anything that you
can't carry on your back is gonna be in
the middle of our base tomorrow morning
it's getting shipped out on helicopters
so people went crazy are you kidding me
well not only that you know what he did
and I'm sure you know this but he took
away class a meals oh I did not know
that or I don't remember it because they
were so they were so how to say this
nicely they they were not disciplined
okay because they had lousy leadership
before that and hackers basically said
you know you guys are soldiers and he
said I'm gonna keep you alive you know
but you're gonna have to soldier so he
actually took classes away initially he
made them shine their boots indefinitely
I mean you know stuff that sounds crazy
yeah you know but he was getting their
attention yeah you know and and cleaning
weapons I mean they would you know they
were not cleaning I mean how crazy is
that they weren't cleaning their weapons
at night time there was night this of
the light discipline was
almost non-existent I mean it was crazy
and Hackworth made him you know soldier
up and and but then what happened was
they started to uses tactics and they
found out that hey this works I mean
we're not taking casualties like we did
before we're actually inflicting
casualties that we weren't doing before
and then he started to give stuff back
oh you know what else he did he took
away beer there was like water you know
the average temperature was like 95
degrees you know and all that it was
like 3.2 or whatever the beer was you
know but he took that away initially too
they and people thought he was nuts yeah
actually there's a great quote in about
face it's some guy writing home to his
is just a quote from a letter somebody
wrote doubt wrote you know my new come
my new battalion commanders crazy I
don't know what's gonna happen that's
literally a letter or a guy right home
it's interesting to me so I've seen this
and I'm sure you've seen this in your
career I've seen it in the business
world I'm sure you've seen the business
world in the military guys that go so
far in that direction of being so
hardcore and over-the-top that they
break their guys and people actually
don't like them and they don't want to
serve them and they don't want to do a
good job because they're they're they're
too focused on stuff that doesn't really
matter and Hackworth just he seemed to
have this ability to balance it so well
between being hardcore and yet at the
same time everybody knows that he's
gonna take care of many loves him yeah
that that was the main thing cuz they
knew that they were gonna they were
gonna live under his command if they
followed what he said mm-hmm and there
would be successful - don't forget the
success breeds success and so the hard
core is as they kept on progressing
became prouder and prouder of you know
and the guys you know it was just a unit
that nobody wanted to reckon with
no and that's how it was but Hank led by
example I can't I just can't emphasize
that enough you know I I have my
leadership mantra which and I'm a simple
guy so I boil boil things down simply
and the three words example carrying and
balance and you got a lead by personal
example it's not you know do what I say
but do what I do and carrying it's the
care for your soldiers and you know
carrying means especially in combat
keeping them alive that's how you care
for me and you train tough you know I
mean Hackworth always mentioned that you
know the harder you train you know the
the better that they'll perform in
combat in fact sometimes it was easier
in combat and you know some of the
training they need make them go through
and and finally is balance too
especially leaders not talking to
leaders right and I always told my
leaders that you've got to maintain a
balance between your professional
military job and your family and I used
to tell my guys you're not doing me any
good if you're going through a divorce
you know and too many guys it's easy
when you get promoted to get kind of
caught up in the perks and then the
responsibility you know so you work
harder to be more and then what do you
do you ignore your family and then
things fall apart and so I I've worn my
my soldiers I always said you know
maintain that balance and I tried to do
that not only personally but they to get
my soul when we were mobilized for
example okay my division now this was
not we didn't deploy overseas we were a
training division our wartime mission
was the Army Reserves by the way it was
the only service that had this we we had
reservists who's wartime mission was to
take over the training of the recruits
at the active duty stations which would
then release those active duty soldiers
to go join
forces made a lot of sense you know so
so when that happened I I went to my
staff now you have to understand this is
like the late 80s right okay and I went
to my staff and I said I want a 24-hour
800 number from my family Support
Program
I want my soldiers to know and I want
their spouses to know that while they're
deployed if there is any problems they
can count on us and I want it to be 24/7
man and they said general well you have
to understand those days 800 murders
were pretty expensive and and and they
said you know number one is gonna be
expensive number two you know with 24/7
you know and I said make it happen
because I last thing I wanted my
soldiers who are deployed to worry about
was their families right and then what I
did is I yeah I had the two stars
stationary you know when it's a Major
General little notes you know they're
not eating half by 11 their little note
things so I told my staff I want to send
a personally signed note to every spouse
or significant other of a deployed
soldier in this division and I'm on a
note to go to their employer because you
have to understand these are reservist
mm-hmm right okay so I had 1,500
soldiers mobilize right so this is 3,000
letters that I'm gonna sign you know
personally they wanted me to use an auto
auto pen you know buying my computer it
you know manufacture your signature I
said no way these are these are going
you know so I I did that and what
happened was I was I had a cousin whose
husband was a steel seal salesman okay
and she calls me one day and she said
you'll never know what happened to my
husband he was making a call on this
company in Indiana
okay and on the wall was one of my
letters Burcu to them and he saw my name
on it
you know so caring for your carrying and
balance is important yeah yeah you know
you talked about that that operation
that was so well planned and so well
executed and you talked about hack warts
sort of Sixth Sense instinct and then
you know I've heard you talking some
other interviews about a situation that
you were in that was that you described
as really sort of impacting your your
mental state and to me when I heard you
talk about it it seemed to be almost
like a turning point mentally
psychologically for you and it had to do
with you over running a position and and
you end up with some some yeah I didn't
I didn't realize the impact of that
incident until many many years later but
in order for me to explain that I have
to talk about something called moral
injury which is an when the so called
invisible wounds of war a lot of people
are familiar with post-traumatic stress
disorder a lot of people are aware of
traumatic brain injury but when you ask
them if they could describe the
invisible wound of war called moral
injury very few people are knowledgeable
about that how long has that term been
used there was a psychiatrist at the VA
doctor Jonathan Shay who basically
coined that phrase in 2009 so it's been
around for a while and now it's starting
to really pick up steam in research
because of its significance in
contributing to the high suicide rate
among veterans and the concept is is
when I go around and I give
presentations and and I tell people the
concept is so intuitive you'll get it in
seconds okay so here it is from the time
you're born until you're 18 years old
you develop a personal moral code sense
of right or wrong that could come from
your family your religion community
friends whatever and then you join the
military and you learn a warrior code
the warrior code is superimposed on your
personal moral code and in fact
transforms that somewhat then you might
have to participate in activities or
operations that violate your personal
moral code such as killing you don't
have to be the person that pulls the
trigger you could be a witness or you
could feel that you should have
prevented it or you could be in a unit
that follows another unit and you see
that innocent civilians have been killed
or you handle body parts at that time
you sustained a so called invisible
wound of war called moral injury it's
not a physical wound you can't see it
but in military operations we're
constantly moving you're going from
point A to point B to Point C you don't
have time to stop and reflect on this
stuff so what do you do you bury it and
it becomes unresolved grief shame and
what happens is you come back to the
states and let's say you leave the
military or you're in the National Guard
or reserves and you've come back to a
community anywhere in the country that
doesn't understand what you've been
through and it boils up to the surface
and unless you have a strong coping
mechanism for that bad stuff happens
anger guilt depression suicide and the
suicide rate among veterans today is
epidemic I mean the VA it's anywhere
from 20 to 22 veterans per day are dying
by suicide and that frankly is
underreported it's really higher than
that because you've got veterans who are
dying by suicide is not reported as a
suicide though drive their motorcycle or
car in
to a tree or viaduct and it's a
vehicular accident or unfortunately
there's something called suicide-by-cop
where they forced the law-enforcement
officer to take lethal action
and so what's what's the implication of
all that we lose more veterans to
suicide in a year than all the combat
dust since 9/11 that's all Germanicus
and we believe that moral injury is a
major contributing factor to that and
military outreach USA our organization
we feel that the main approach to moral
injury is not a medical doctor with
prescription drugs
it's the forgiveness and grace of a
moral authority and the counseling of
clergy and sensitive therapists and the
support of a community offering hope and
help and so now getting back at an
incident that that you asked me about
Jocko I was a company commander battle
company we had just overrun Viet Cong
position and killed numerous enemy and I
literally had three dead bodies at my
feet okay well the time a unit is most
vulnerable is right after a victory it's
just human nature to let your guard down
and breathe a sigh of relief why I'm the
guy in charge I know that so I'm on my
radio and I'm kicking rear end and
taking names I'm telling my platoon
leaders we organize your units we
distribute ammunition take care of your
wounded look for enemy avenues of
approach for a counter-attack right and
in the middle of all that stuff going on
I stopped and I looked at the three dead
bodies at my feet I realized that
something had happened to me
something had hardened my heart only
moments earlier these were alive human
beings they had families they had
emotions they had loved ones they were
fighting for something as important to
them as I was fighting for and I was in
their band
yard and then I remember Jesus is Sermon
on the Mount where he told us to pray
for our enemies so in the midst of all
this stuff going on I said a prayer for
the three Vietcong and I know I was
praying for myself as much as I was
praying for them now you know I didn't
have a big ceremony get on my hands and
knees any of that stuff you know this
all took about 45 seconds but it's
something that was seared in my heart
and mind for the rest of my life and now
that I know about morale and injury okay
which I didn't know at that time I
realize that I was one in a million who
was able to address my moral injury at
the time that happened okay and you know
I'd always when I came here from Vietnam
I had seen a lot of my comrades having
nightmares having flashbacks
you know personality changes and I
frankly asked myself how come I'm not
going through that okay and at the time
my answer always was my faith and my
wife my wonderful wife of now 46 years
who is an angel I've been so blessed
having her for a wife so that was my
answer okay but now since I've been
dealing with military outreach USA and
this issue of moral injury I realized
that my answer was really lacking okay
there were two other things one was that
incident in Vietnam that I just
mentioned to you but the other thing
which I now realize is when I came back
from Vietnam I joined the reserves okay
and I was able to maintain my sense of
purpose of being in a unit with other
people who share the same values that I
did of patriotism of dedication of
selfless service which a lot of veterans
when they come back they just want to
cut ties totally and they a lot of them
drift because they they don't have that
sense of purpose
they don't have the camaraderie they
don't have the bonding you know I had
that with the reservist especially you
know in Viet you know with Vietnam and
all the BS did we had to take from the
public you know I mean you won't believe
this way well I know you know this but
when we came here from Vietnam we were
told not to wear our uniforms in public
I mean that's how bad it was
that's crazy you know guys wore wigs so
they people wouldn't know they had short
haircuts mmm
you know because they could pick them up
as being military and so my being in the
reserves helped me you know maintain
that one of the things that I tell guys
is very similar to what you just said
you know I tell guys you got to find a
new mission when you get done when you
get done with the military you got to
find a new mission and if you can stay
in reserves obviously that that gives
you that but if you don't do that well
then you got to find what are you gonna
do what are you gonna step out there are
you gonna become a great dad are you
gonna build a business are you gonna
work for a company and do a great job or
you got to find a new mission and I find
that guys that I've seen that that have
real problems it's because they got out
and they didn't know didn't have any
direction to go into I also what just to
dig a little bit deeper so you're in
that situation where you see these guys
and and and for the first time you you
kind of look down on them and see them
as people as other human beings is it
you know is it the fact that you when
you when you set a prayer for them and
for yourself I kind of got an thought of
when you hear about like Native
Americans hunting and you know they they
think you know when that when they get a
kill though they'll thank the you know
mother nature and and thank for the
sacrifice was it that type of thing
where you said okay you know what we're
fighting I'm I was doing my job you guys
were doing your job and I hope you have
peace now when it was it that type of
thing absolutely because you know what
happens is you forget that they're there
dehumanized but you know you've got all
these all these names that you call them
you know but I really respected the VC
our enemy you know that's a that's the
other thing you can't underestimate your
enemy
you always have to respect them you have
you know I mean you don't have to agree
with them but you you you have to
respect their abilities because once you
lose track of that you can really get
screwed and basically I'll give you some
examples when we had that battle on 22
May okay I wasn't the cnc helicopter
with and i guess i should describe that
battle a little bit more seer
listeners we're talking about the
hardcore battalion and when we surround
this this this vc training battalion
really is what it was and we annihilated
it basically they were in they were
encircled and we were just calling her
in airstrikes naval gunfire you know we
were just take and then hackworth had
him totally encircled and so i'll never
forget i was in the helicopter with him
and he basically said mooc we got a
first we get a radio message from one of
our companies it might have been an
alert company and they said we just had
a contact you know we killed three we've
can't you know we got four weapons we
captured a guy or whatever and they're
headed in this direction
okay so hackers would turn to me and say
MOOC you know let's say give him 15
minutes we're gonna hear from battle
company 15 minutes later battle company
comes up we just had her contact you
know in their head and so this happened
all day okay i saw this i was with him
then the helicopter and but there was
one vc we were flying near a canal and
he was mortally wounded you could see
the guy was dying basically he took his
ak-47 and he threw it into the canal
okay and the reason he did that is he
didn't want us to get that weapon
because part of the body count was you
matched how many weapons you you know if
a univee portland they said well we kill
20 and we got one weapon you kind of say
wait a second mm-hmm
you know so when I saw that I knew that
this guy you know we were up against a
tough enemy mm-hmm
you know and and so so you got to
respect your enemy and I want to pull
some before we move past Vietnam and
hack I want to pull some stuff out of
about-face just to kind of hear you hear
your your thoughts on it I'm gonna start
off with one that you've talked about a
little bit but here we go this is from
about faced by david hackworth and this
is a quote from someone else
it says hack had the knack of being able
to size people up very quickly almost
instantaneously and I'd say 99% of the
time he was right he could look at a
person and in his vernacular the guy was
either a stud or he wasn't there was no
in-between if he was a stud hack would
find a way to get him and he would not
take no from people if he wanted them
because he wanted a winning team and if
a person didn't want to go with him then
immediately the guy wasn't a stud you
see because anybody who knew hack or
came into contact with him really wanted
to be with him after he'd known him for
a while and that's a quote from
Brigadier General James H Fukuyama
which is you you're quoted in the book
and you've talked about that a little
bit and he just had he must have
extremely magnetic personality for you
to say that if you spent time with him
you wanted to be with him oh absolutely
and and he I used to say he had the
Midas touch everything the guy touched
just whether it was in the military
whether it was in business whether it
was with women and this guy you know he
was a stud himself and and you know and
but he was he was also a sensitive guy
I'll never forget when
you know I tell people he wasn't the
most moral guy that I knew but he was
the the most ethical officer I ever
served with what I mean by that is he
never did anything for personal gain
he always did things for the unit and
for the soldiers okay but did he have
affairs and things like that yeah and he
used to tell me he said mu you know I
should have never married because my
love is the army mmm you know so he he
basically he turned down the War College
he could have gone to the workout she
turned it down because he said hey I'm
on another battalion mm-hmm in Vietnam
you know I mean he would have been a
journal there's no question about it had
he not stood up you know when he was no
six and and and you know he was I think
he was the youngest oh six at that time
in the army but he was a guy who who was
he was sensitive though and he took her
he did take care of his family I think I
can say this now because it's you know I
think statute of limitations might be
gone but you know in those days you
weren't you weren't able to take a lot
of cash out of Vietnam you know and and
I basically one day when he knew I was
going back home oh and by the way he did
everything he could to convince me to
stay and to extend in Vietnam okay he
was he had moved down to be the the
senior advisor for the arvin Airborne
Division which was meeting the palace
guard around Saigon okay
and he knew all my hot buttons you have
to understand I was a bachelor guy at
this time right and and and the airborne
the Vietnamese airborne wore special
fatigues they were like Tiger fatigue
and they had red berets you know and I'm
just this young stud guy who likes
uniforms and he said Mook he said why
don't you come down here and I'll make
you the g1 advisor that's the admin guy
right and he said but when you come down
if you're an advisor for the
Vietnamese Arab woman you get jumpy you
know so that's extra money right yeah
and he said and I'll give you two are in
ours you can because he knew I wanted to
go to Japan and see my relatives so in
six months he said give you to our nurse
right so guys you know he's trying to
move the you know the Sun and the moon
to get me to extend six months and and I
said sir I appreciate it but I had some
close calls and I figured the next one
would have Mowgli amma written that
bullet would him look Wilma written on
it and I said no thanks you know I
appreciate it but I'm out of here so so
I left you know you're talking about the
way he was you know so so pro army and
yet he rebelled against the army in a
way and here's a another thing from the
book he says what a mistake it was to
listen to the generals of corporate HQ
who were briefed only in zero defect
terms and so far from the cutting edge
expected nothing less
it was amongst the biggest mistakes of
the war the politicians only listen to
these generals and the generals only
listened to themselves few people asked
frontline soldiers the only ones who
really knew could you guys or could you
because you were pretty close to him
could you sense that his frustration
with the army did he talk about it with
you did he how did he treat you know
that's a very hard thing for a leader to
do if you're if your senior leadership
is telling you to do stuff that doesn't
make sense or but you know hey we can
get it done and we're gonna do it it's a
hard line to walk to say look we support
the chain of command this is what
they're tell him to do I want to spin it
in a positive way everyone's gonna think
that we're doing it for the right
reasons because if I say hey look MOOC
here's what I want you to do and it's
it's dumb but we're getting told to do
it anyway so that's not a good way to
lead no so he wouldn't say that so he
would he would support the chain and he
would he would
presented in the in the way in which you
know you've talked about the mission and
he would make sure that he would
accomplish the mission but he would do
it his way you know you know the phrase
battlefield expediency that's so we did
all the time you know I mean screw it
what you know what are they gonna do
send us to Vietnam we're already there
you know so you know we just did what we
had to do and you know I mean the stupid
rules of engagement that we had you know
where you'd have to get approval to fire
on people even though you're receiving
fire you know and and just nutty stuff
you know and we just say hey you know
we're gonna do what we have to do and
that's what we did mm-hmm
here's what he when he took over the
battalion the following day I took over
the battalion from Lieutenant Colonel
Franklin a Hartle in a parade field
exchange of command in the middle of the
mekong delta what kind of war have I got
myself into I wondered a perfectly
starched general Ewell was there having
flown in for the occasion in his
polished choppers there was other brass
too and photographers the American flag
the battalion colors which were
ceremoniously passed on to me and all of
this before the scroungy estas
spiritless assembly of soldiers I'd ever
seen
incredibly none of the generals or
Colonels seemed to notice the slack
condition of my new charges or their
positions from the outset I realized
that to make this unit effective
military force I'd have to implement
about a thousand changes so I figured
we'd start with five a day little things
basic things like where your steel pot
and clean and carry your rifle at all
times an ammunition will not be worn
Pancho Villa's style my first order was
that darkness that come darkness the
fire support base perimeter would pull
back 300 meters the troops instantly
began to grumble about this but it was
the next order that really began the
mutinous feeling within my hard luck
outfit anything you can't carry 24 hours
a day is gone in the next chop chopper
goodbye tents and cots and rucksacks and
Phu
Gawker's the bitching and moaning began
in earnest as piles and piles of junk
mounted at the LZ to be whisked away by
Chinook but I didn't care I wasn't there
to have them like me again we already
talked about this
and I this comes up a lot from a
leadership perspective do you is it more
important to be liked or is it more
important to be respected is it more
important to and I actually had a guy
asked me this question the other day is
it more important to win or to be liked
and I said well those two things aren't
mutually exclusive at all you're right
you're absolutely correct and they're
not mutually exclusive you know if you
demonstrate to your soldiers that you
care for them professionally that's
you'll be liked there's no question
because they know that you're there for
them and you know you don't as as it's
said there you know you're not there to
win a popularity contest you know you're
not there to be politically correct
you're there to accomplish your mission
but also make sure that your guys come
back and I think I'm starting to tie
together something very clearly in my
head right now and that is you know
you're your number two rule of
leadership which is caring and I think
if you if you care about your people and
they see that you care about them that
Trump's the fact that you want them to
do things the right way because the
reason you want them to do the things
right way is because you care about them
and it's gonna keep alive make you
successful yeah absolutely absolutely
you know I when I was a young officer I
well no I at that time when I was a
company come after Hackworth left we had
a another battalion commander come in
right and he wrote on my OER all my
career I had Maxo er's
really good stuff but on this one he
wrote that and I'll take this hit and
day of the week he said I was too
concerned for my troops sometimes and
and I said ok I'll take that wow that's
that's a interesting perspective yeah
and you know this is one of those
dichotomies as well because one of the
hardest things about being a leader is
obviously you care about your men so
much and yet you are gonna do things you
are gonna put them in situations that
there's gonna put their lives at risk at
risk and that is that is something that
every leader has to release military
leaders they have to they have to find a
way to get a handle on that because you
love your guys and you want to take care
of them but you do have to do your
mission you know in that that's one of
the hardest things to balance talking
about the morality of war a little bit
this was a and again this is why you
know that the story that I opened up
with you could see that that one clearly
had to do with with having moral
dilemmas and having guilt because
hackworth gave a guy in order and the
guy followed the order maybe not the way
hacker thought he was but the moral
injury that he got from that he said
lasted his whole life of giving an order
and somebody does something you didn't
expect to him they end up getting killed
it's one of his guys when his guys that
he loved gets killed because of the way
he led here's another kind of moral
situation going back to the book they're
flying around they're on a mission we
went down to about 100 feet the suspects
were still running
but this closer inspection confirmed my
initial feeling they were just eight
kids no older than 13 or 14 simply
scared shitless as they ran looking for
cover
carrying neither weapons nor military
equipment no I told the pilot I don't
give you permission to fire I'll put an
infantry insert on them I instructed the
platoon leader whose men were aboard the
four slicks where to land
with gunships covering the platoon hit
the ground the immediately received
small arms fire and took a couple of
wounded the little kids were as my savvy
pilot had said from the outset Vietcong
it was a major lesson learned for me but
one impossible to etch in stone I had a
couple of men wounded who would not have
been if I just said to blow those kids
away but I couldn't say blow him away
because they appeared unarmed yes they
were VC but they could just as well have
been kids ditching school who happened
to get caught in the crossfire anything
was possible and I suddenly realized it
would not be easy this Delta war it
wasn't easy to tell the good guys from
the bad guys anywhere in South Vietnam
but here in the Delta it was damn near
impossible again very similar to what my
guys dealt with over in Ramadi was very
hard to tell who was good and who was
bad and the enemy knew they could just
put the you know drop the weapon and
walk away and now they were considered
innocent even though 20 seconds prior to
that they were shooting how did you keep
your men from becoming so callous that
they were just gonna start shooting kids
because they suspected they were VC how
hard did you have to keep control of
that well I my response to that is the
American soldier innately is ethical
it's it's in our culture not to shoot
women and children now guys you know if
they're you know that that that might be
something else but we and we do not
shoot civilians just you know who are
who are were caught with you know we run
across them just because they're there
and we want to take revenge
don't do that as an army you're
generally speaking now there are times
when people lose it and I understand
that that's that's the stress of war
that's happened in all wars mm-hmm I
don't condone it but I can understand
and so to answer your question we really
didn't have to our guys were pretty
professional and I was probably proud to
serve with them I didn't they didn't I
didn't see any of that okay yeah yeah
and this just just tells me once again
it's about leadership because here you
can see HACC clearly leaning towards
making sure he's doing the right thing
even though he's a guy that loves his
troops and wants to take care of him he
still leans towards doing the right
thing and from what you're saying that
filtered all the way through the chain
of command and we we took an in-depth
look I've actually done two podcasts
concerning the meal I mascar and what
happened there and it was just so clear
that the leadership was completely at
fault and the way that they led those
troops and it was when I went through to
try and pull something positive out of
the meal I Massacre the positive message
that I got from it was that it was one
it was one officer who had flown it was
Thompson I believe his name was but he'd
flown over he'd seen what was happening
he flew back to base told the the senior
leadership this is what's going on on
the ground the senior leadership radioed
in to the field and said stop killing
people and the they literally instantly
stopped they stopped the massacre just
because a leader stepped up and said
stop so good leadership completely
changed the situation as it was ongoing
and and clearly if there would've been a
better leader on the ground that was
leading in the right way it never would
have even started so you can see here
from what hack saying the way he led and
the way he treated unknown people and
then the way that was carried out
through the whole battalion that's
another amazing testament to good
leadership yeah and and one thing about
me ly which I tell people is that it was
the exception that proves the rule that
the United States military
that that was an exception oh yeah yeah
you know the the rule in our military is
we don't we don't do that and that
proved it I mean I I didn't see you know
there were other armies there who were
more ruthless like the like the rocks
mm-hmm
the rocks were not there the Republic of
Korea they were not there the wind the
hearts and minds of the people mm-hmm
they were there to win the war so if
they would go by a village and they were
fired upon they'd destroy the village
and after a while nobody fired on the
rocks mm-hmm
when Hackworth now gets wood he got
wounded in eighth time yeah well you I
thought you were getting to that when
you read that one quote but the way now
I wasn't there with him when he when he
got his eighth Purple Heart but I know
the story and and basically there were
guys who were in in bad shape and he
lands the CNC in the middle of them in
fact that might have been it and maybe
you they landed it in the middle of a
firefight or hacked it he ordered the
pilot that take him down and he does put
the wounded guys into the CNC well the
CNC isn't that big you know there's no
room for hack so he stands on the skids
and they take off and he gets hit in the
leg and that was his eighth Purple Heart
well after that you know he could tell
the guys in the battalion I want you to
walk through this wall of fire and the
response would be where do you want us
to go you know he led by example mm-hmm
but is that what caused the army to say
okay we're gonna did they pull it did
they pull him from the battalion at that
point when he got his aid yeah pretty
much that was that was it cuz well it
was if you got three purple hearts you
went home without it was that the deal I
don't know I only had one I have no idea
but you know they they basically said
you know we can't afford to lose you I
mean if they you know if you get killed
I mean that's a big hit and just a
morale and you know
and so your honor you're out of there in
the field
mm-hmm okay so he went up to plate who
to become the deputy he was the g3 core
advisor for two core okay which was the
Central Highlands and when my company
was pulled out of Vietnam and I refused
to go and I said hey I want to stay here
I called hatch and I said sir you know I
don't really want to go back can you use
me
I had orders the next day to go to play
whoo and then you went up to play Coon
and you start you guys were doing
advising for the Arvin yes we were the
we were the McVie that's the military
assistance command Vietnam people and I
had there was a close call that I had
when this was another moral injury thing
by the way which I really had really
buried had not really thought a lot
about it but we we had an inspection
team that went out on the Special Forces
camps around the border of Cambodia and
Laos and Vietnam and he had laser rang
than had docto in the central highlands
and so we would fly into these camps and
there were three people on this
inspection team so to speak it was the
deputy coroner who was a no.6 a full
colonel
you know big deal there was the command
sergeant major highest ranking enlisted
advisor also a big deal and I was the
young captain okay carrying everybody's
bags note-takers yeah right so so we
land on this Special Forces camp and we
come under attack and the sergeant major
is killed and he was maybe 20 meters
away from me
it was a rocket and it was just he was
in the wrong place you know it could
have been me if I was you know if they'd
come in the other direction
well the back side of that story is that
he was scheduled to go on ahran
the next day to Hawaii to meet his
waiting wife to celebrate their 25th
wedding anniversary okay
now obviously I was just a young captain
but I outranked him okay
I could have ordered him not to go on
that mission why risk it you know
because he he was gonna meet his wife
the next day I didn't do that okay and I
I've thought about that in terms of
survivor guilt and and all of that it
was and that's something that's come up
in my you know my studying this moral
injury stuff at this point did you you
sure now you're working with Hackworth
directly and are you starting to sense
his frustration about the war at all
yeah a little bit yeah well no more than
a little bit because the the the g34 the
core was fairly corrupt a guy and
hackworth was very frustrated with that
and that's why he left actually
well let's backtrack I I yeah he he was
moved down to the Vietnamese airborne
because he really was not happy I think
he might have been moved I never really
got the story on that why he went down
there and now at this point what's your
what are you thinking about your career
in your life
oh I'd already decided I was resigning
when I got back to the states and what
made you what made you lean in that
direction because I mean you did more
years in Junior ROTC than anyone has
ever done before visited ROTC and you
had all that military stuff and now you
got your combat tour in Vietnam under
what what what tilted you in the other
direction
I felt the Army was going in the wrong
direction when it came to leadership I
thought that they were
looking for managers and not commanders
I was in some positions during my career
where I had access to officer efficiency
reports and I could see were the ratings
of the senior officers that lieutenant
Colonel's and the battalion commanders
were the tendency was to give the
managers high ratings Erie's
irrespective of their command and
abilities and and then my personal
career was was not managed very well
hackworth Hackworth wanted me to stay he
knew I was I was thinking of resigning
in fact that's why he offered me the
company because you know he thought that
experience might turn things around you
know and so on Here I am at still with
hackworth in the battalion right and he
contacted his friends at the Pentagon
and he said listen you guys we got a
stud here and he's thinking of leaving
you know show him some personal
attention we got a chance to save him
you know he told me this later and so I
get this letter from the Pentagon you
know I'm out in the middle of nowhere
you know and I first letter they'd ever
sent me and they said dear Campton
Moakley um we have reviewed your 201
file very carefully right and we believe
you have promised for graduate school
okay only problem is I already had my
man which means that they didn't really
pay a lot of tension right there review
I I showed the letter to him and I said
hey you know I mean this is crazy you
know I'm gonna put my career in the
hands of these guys you know and that
pretty well sealed it for me and so did
you did you submit your resignation
while you were still in Vietnam were to
come home as soon as I came home I did I
wanted to finish the tour in Vietnam
which I did and then I told the army I'm
gonna be out of here
you know and so they assigned me to Fort
Sheridan Illinois right because I
in Chicago and I finished I have three
months there and then I was done and
then did you at what point did you
decide you were gonna stay in the
reserves Oh immediately okay that was
never a question okay I was committed to
doing 20 years turned out to be 32 but I
you know I was committed to doing 20
because especially at that time then
the reserve components didn't have a lot
of combat experience guys and I felt
that it was important that I try to help
you know the reserves be ready basically
and I had something to contribute so
that's why I joined the reserves and
then you start on your civilian career
yeah as well yeah and what happened
there was I I worked for a Japanese
importing and exporting company it's
called a trading company and it was name
of company was Matsui and company's
world we know we used to have a saying
that the Sun never set on Mitsui because
they had offices in like 165 countries
okay and it was a very prestigious
company if anybody they had
quote-unquote Mitsui men you know if you
were a Mitsui guy that was a big deal it
was like their Harvard graduates would
all go there you know and things like
that and I was at the Chicago office and
the problem was I actually experienced
reverse discrimination by that what I
mean is that I had studied Japanese
history political science and Japanese
language a little bit at the University
of Illinois okay and I had a pretty good
work ethic okay and but they couldn't it
couldn't compute in their mind that I
talked about the Japanese okay all the
manager positions were Japanese like the
branch manager he was a vice president
you know and all that I had no
opportunity to ever get to even to be a
department manager in that company
because they looked at me and they
couldn't compute that I didn't speak
Japanese fluently okay so in their mind
I'm the village idiot you know even
though I have my master's degree and
commanded a company in combat I had
signed for ten million dollars worth of
equipment I had more responsibilities in
life than these guys who ever know you
know but they didn't get it they didn't
understand that so I did that for about
five years I mean I was treated well I
have no complaints but you know I didn't
expect any guarantees but I had hoped I
would have an opportunity to compete
mm-hm and when I saw that wasn't that
that wasn't going to happen I had a
roommate from the U of I who was a
member of the Chicago Board Options
Exchange and options trading was just
starting at that time and he was a great
visionary a little weak on details and
so he had an operation on the floor of
the exchange and he realized he needed
to get a handle on that and I'm pretty
good with details so he called me and he
said Jim I know you're not happy you
know where you're at
would you want to come work with me and
and I said hey wait a second you know I
don't have one day of Finance formal
education I didn't know the difference
between a stock and a bond or you know
muscle s a stock option and he said
don't worry about it I know your
abilities you're good with math you know
this is not rocket scientist stuff and I
said okay I'll do it in that started out
of 35 year career in the financial
services industry and I became a member
of the New York Stock Exchange the
Chicago Board Options Exchange I was
very blessed
I became part owner the company so that
enabled me to devote all the time I did
in the reserves that I did because that
was part of the deal I made with my
friend I said listen if you want me to
join you I'm bringing the reserves with
me and you have to understand you know
if I'm called on going
and if I'm in the reserves I'm gonna
give it a hundred percent you know and
and but he was he had gone through our
TC with me okay so he was he was an army
officer so he understood so I was able
to have a successful career at the same
time and you moved up really quickly
through the ranks in the reserves yeah I
had I had like like I said before Jocko
I had great NCOs who made me look good I
had commanders who mentored me I was I
was a brigadier general at the age of 42
and I was a major-general three years
later I was the youngest general in the
Army at the time so yeah I was I was
challenged I had great assignments and
so I was very blessed and my wife
supported me through all of this without
her I would not have been able to get
the first base I noticed you you
mentioned a couple times General William
Levine yes and and the impact that he
had on you he was a guy that landed a
d-day at Utah Beach and was one of the
people that liberated Dachau and in
World War two
yes did was there any significant lesson
learned that he passed on to you there
absolutely he he I think he's personally
responsible for that balanced part of my
leadership concept that I've developed
over my career he really emphasized
family and keep in mind when I joined
the reserves I didn't have a clue about
the citizen soldier you know those of us
on and of duty what do we know about the
garden reserves and their pressure you
know what they deal with you know people
in the garden reserves have to balance
three balls at the same time right
you've got your your family you've got
your civilian career that puts bread and
butter on the table and then you've got
the reserves on the guard you know what
you know and so you're balancing all
that stuff and general Lavigne I always
remember emphasize the family he always
made sure that we were aware of
the stresses on the family you know when
we were gone I'll never forget in my
career without fail that's when the
furnace would break down that's when
we'd have a blizzard so my 95 pound wife
would have to go out there and shovel
the snow cuz I wasn't there you know our
son Jay who's who you know he he
basically was a rascal when he was a
young guy and my Mike had to take him to
the emergency room in the hospital like
three times I don't even know where
three times a week
and I don't even know where it's at you
know cuz I wasn't home so you know the
stresses on the fit so he really drove
that home and I understood better the
stresses on the citizen-soldier which
are tremendous you know at least when
you're on active duty you're focused
mm-hmm you know and you're in a
community where everybody is going
through the same thing so they all
understand you know the stresses on the
marriage they you know they share things
they can help each other out but in the
reserves and guard you know the rest of
the you go to a meeting one week in a
month you know and unless you're in
leadership you know that's about it and
you know you don't have the you don't
have the bonding and the community
strength that you do when you're under
duty yeah when we got to Ramadi it was
the two to eight National Guard unit out
of Pennsylvania and reserve units that
were on the ground and they'd been there
for I think they've been there for 14
months but boy they were outstanding
soldiers all of them it was a real honor
to work with them a little bit and then
get the turnover and great guys
they you ran you ended up running
training for like twenty one out of your
25 years in the reserves that's that's
that's a lot of training to run yeah I
was and once again I'd say you've heard
me say this before it's a god thing
basically the army was the only service
that really had a great process where we
had
Reserve units whose wartime mission was
to take over the training centers you
know like the Great Lakes Naval Training
Center you know but the Navy didn't have
that the Air Force didn't have that the
Marines didn't him that we had reserve
units that their wartime mission was to
go to Fort Benning for example that was
my divisions mission was to go to Fort
Benning and take over the training of
the infantry officers and and recruits
not officers to recruits at Fort Benning
so that the active-duty soldiers that
were already there who are up to speed
on everything you know could go join
fighting units basically so that was
that was the mission all right so I
joined when I came off of active duty I
joined the 85th training division in
Chicago and that was an infantry
training division at the time and I was
with them for 18 years and I commanded
at the company level battalion level
Brigade level and I was the assistant
division commander and every year we
would go on annual training to a
active-duty training fort and we take
over the training of the recruits so I
did it at Dix I did it at Fort Bliss I
did it at Fort Ord and then finally with
the seventieth I did it at Fort Benning
and so then what happened was I I was
the commander of the 70th division out
of Livonia Michigan and Desert Storm
came okay and I knew we were going to be
mobilized
you know the handwriting was on the wall
okay so I put together a list I had 16
subordinate units in my devaglia three
brigades and the Training Command and
other things and so I made a list of
ones through 16 and I prioritized them
okay and I and it was a mixture of
readiness
leadership you know that's how I
prioritize them and I also had to be
sensitive to I had units in Indiana and
Michigan so I couldn't take all the
Michigan units and leave out Indiana
guys that wouldn't have been fair
because everybody wanted to be mobilized
yeah okay you have to understand this
was this is when this would be the first
time okay and we've been practicing for
like 25 years you know you're ready for
game day yeah so the question is if the
balloon went up would people show up you
know and so so I had this list and I
went to TRADOC which was our higher
headquarters at Fort Monroe Virginia and
I said listen here's my list here's my
division okay I said use this list and
if you're gonna mobilize my division or
any part of my division do it in
disorder and don't screw with this this
is the best way this is the best way my
division will serve you know the army
did they comply oh yeah they were
delighted possessive I was the only
division commander that had done that so
they went out to the other 11 division
commanders and hey hey say we need some
lists you know and that and they did
exactly what I told them to do because
they mobilized half of my division so
they just went right down the list you
know down to eight or nine and that was
it you know now you ended up having kind
of a runnin at the end of your career
yeah I had several you know notice
because of half words you know about
face and and and the first one was I
went on The Oprah Winfrey Show and
basically my mom was still alive at that
time she used to watch Oprah during the
day and Oprah was out of Chicago right
that's right and and then she and she
used to and I didn't know this because I
never watched it but she used to
announce ahead of time subjects that she
was going to cover and if anybody knew
any
one who were experts in that area let
her know you know so she could get them
so she decided this is in the late 80s
okay now put yourself back at that time
when the economy was not doing so hot
and the Japanese economy was doing real
good
you know because their computers their
automobiles their televisions and so
people were blaming the Japanese about
our poor economic situation and it was
called Japan bashing mm-hm so in fact
there was a Chinese guy's name was
Victor Chen who was killed in Detroit by
some automobile workers with baseball
bats because they thought he was
Japanese he was actually Chinese okay so
open decided they have a show about
Japan bashing so she said if anybody
knows anyone you know in the Japanese
American community to what might be a
good you know person on this please let
me know well my mom saw that and she
said you need to get on the show
you know so I tried calling I couldn't
get you know how this is you know I
couldn't get through whatever well I
have a very I had at that time a very
influential journalist in Chicago his
name was Irv cups in it who had a very
famous
it's called cups column he used to
interview presidents kings and queens
political people you know at in Chicago
and at a restaurant and so so I called
cup I said hey cut you know I'm trying
to get through on this thing with Oprah
and and he said I'll see what I can do
okay
two hours later I get a call from the
executive producer at the show and he
says I understand that you're a general
in the army I said yeah I'm I'm in the
Army Reserves and and that you're the
highest-ranking ancient American and our
armed forces today and I said yeah
that's right
and he said well and and I I was trying
to figure out where the guy was going
right well he was trying to see if I
could chew gum and walk at the same time
so once he figured I could do that he
said
you know we'd like to have you on the
show okay so I said fine when is it
tomorrow okay so I said okay I'm in so I
called my at that time I was working for
a New York Stock Exchange firm and I
called the headquarters in New York I
said hey I need a day offs and they gave
it to me and then I called the Chief of
Army Reserves office because keep in
mind on the two-star general right and I
said hey I'm going on The Oprah Show you
know and what's the subject well the
subject is Japan bashing but I'm being
invited because you know I'm
high-ranking Japanese American in our
army and I'm gonna wear my uniform you
know so I get a call back okay from the
chief of public affairs of the army now
he's a one-star okay okay and I'm a
two-star okay so he calls and he said I
understand you're gonna be on The Oprah
Show yeah that's right what's the
subject Japan bashing oh it's not about
the army no it's not about the military
at all yeah but I'm being invited
because I'm the highest-ranking Japanese
American in the Army in the military the
whole military and being in Norway at
the time and he said well then we don't
want you to wear your uniform okay
and I said listen I take my
responsibilities very seriously as a
role model for minorities this is a
great opportunity to let people know
that we have equal opportunity in our
armed forces I don't see this as a as a
as a possibility to fail I see this is a
opportunity to succeed and I and I just
said I you know I don't really have a
lot of time for this because it's gonna
be the next day right so I said is this
an order you know um you know the
secretary or from the chief I don't care
you know whoever's above me is this an
order and he said why I can't tell you
it's an order I said well okay in that
case thank you very much for calling me
you know
I appreciate what you said I've taken it
all in under consideration bottom line
I'm wearing my uniform and that was the
end of it okay
so he writes a memorandum for record
that to the chief of staff in the army
that went into my file that said you
know I spoke to general mama I told him
that was you know above his pay grade
levels and he might get involved with
you know things that went out of hand
and all that and he basically told me
that he was gonna wear his uniform so so
I go on the show okay and I'm ready I do
my homework okay and we come back from
commercial break and Oprah starts out by
saying and today we have with us Major
General Jim Buckley AMA the
highest-ranking asian-american
japanese-american in our military today
camera and I'm gonna sit there in a
civilian suit I mean what kind of a
message would that a ridiculous I was in
my class ace of course okay so and the
first words out of my mouth were Oprah I
want everyone to understand that
whatever I say today is the opinion of
jammu Yama
I am NOT representing the Department of
the army I'm not representing the
Department of Defense however I am a
soldier in the United States Army I'm
proud of it we have equal opportunity in
our armed forces and the message and the
rest of the thing went very well and we
they actually had a guy on there who I
would affectionately refer to as a
redneck and he was blaming the Japanese
for all the problems and some of it was
correct where they weren't fair in in
some of the economic dealings with us
you know they were clear their markets
were not as open to our products as they
should have been but on the other hand
the guy was seeing some nutty stuff like
he said well they're costing us jobs
okay so I said okay who's the fourth
largest automobile manufacturer in the
country the answer Honda America okay
they have a plant in Marysville Ohio
that employed 3,500 Americans okay they
can't close that plan and take it back
there Japan it's in the United States
and I said I'm also tired of hearing
people complain about American quality
because the Honda Civics produced at
that plant
had fewer defects than Honda Civics that
were coming from Japan
JD Powers Anaya I had all this already
don't mess with the general so then I
told him I said and guess what
the steel for that plant comes from
Indiana which is also jobs for Americans
okay then the other thing the guy said
was the the the Asians are taking over
our universities I said what's that all
about
and he said well they're getting all the
scholarships okay and I said listen the
Asian Americans are not smarter than any
other ethnicity or race the reason they
do so well in school is the parents get
involved and they make sure that their
kids study and they emphasize the value
of education that got a huge approval
from the audience you know so what
happened was there was a believe it or
not a federal judge in Chicago who saw
that program okay so he writes a letter
to the Secretary of Defense saying you
know unless I saw the Oprah show and
there was this Major General Jim Okayama
who really did a great job for you guys
and you guys should be proud of him
right so the Secretary of Defense at
that time was Dick Cheney okay so he
endorses the letter down to the
Secretary of the army the secretary army
endorses the letter down to the chief of
staff of the army so when that hits my
file same time being
another thing hit my file basically one
cancel the other did you send a
photocopy that back - yeah
but that's you know so right down in
there the army knew what they were
dealing with because I you know I was
you know it was an opportunity to show
that we have equal opportunity Armed
Forces I tell people that one of the
proudest things of my service was that
when I would lose track of people's race
you know I stopped looking at people as
as Asian American or African American
and or Hispanic Americans I looked at
them as private corporal lieutenant
whatever their job was in the military
that's how I caught myself forgetting
sometimes of people you know cuz I tell
people everybody was olive drab there
yeah yeah so that was my first bit first
now you started to say that the book the
book did the book start to play any kind
of role in your career did people start
talking about hack Worth's book no not
really uh that that mean I what I mean
by that is you know the whole stance
that he took about Vietnam to risk his
career and just actually just saying hey
I'm out of here
mmm because you know I've I've done this
now for 30-something years and and
frankly it was weighing on him let me
talk about the moral injury of knowing
that you're leading soldiers in combat
when they could have been the policy
could have been done better right which
would have resulted in fewer casualties
yeah that's that's I don't know if
there's a heavier weight to bear than
that that's a heavy one and then what
was the next thing you took a stance on
well and the next thing that happened
which caused the end of my career
basically is I like that you say that
with a smile on your face
well I I don't regret a day there I
would if I had to do it again today I do
it in a heartbeat and here's what
happened was I was an Army Reserve guy
sold for full transparency to your
listeners okay I was on active duty for
five years I was on an army reservist
for 27 years
okay now the army has three
components they have the active
component they have the Army Reserve and
they have the Army National Guard
okay the the Army Reserve and Army
National Guard are the so-called reserve
components okay
now the active army of course are the
24/7 that's their full-time job the army
reserves are a federal force and the
Army Reserves fall into the normal army
chain of command Department of the army
we answer to the orders of the President
okay Army National Guard does not fall
into that chain of command nor do they
report to the president they be port to
the governors of each state it's really
a state organization although 95 percent
of their budget comes from the federal
government okay
and as an Army reservist
for 25 years 27 years I saw whenever it
came to reducing the army force
structure the Army Reserves would always
get the short end and the guard would
always be protected
okay the actives would always take care
of themselves that was never an issue
okay but the so-called one army concept
where everybody's supposed to be
together in this the reserves always got
the short end of the stick and the
reason for that is the reserves were a
national force okay we were professional
in you know in the military as you know
you're not supposed to be political
you're supposed to be a political
mmm-hmm right not involved in lobbying
and stuff like that the National Guard
is very political it's jobs for the
state mm-hmm
okay so whenever there's the National
Guard has so much political clout if you
look at any presidential election just
watch the week before the election in
November that's when the guard normally
has their National Convention in DC okay
and I can tell you every major
presidential candidate shows up okay and
and keep in mind they have the political
support of a governor two senators and
the congressman right the Army Reserve
doesn't have that political clout so
frankly we've always gotten gotten
screwed
and so I I watched that for 25 years I
said enough is enough and so I I found
it a 501c3 organization called the Army
Reserve Association which was comprised
of officers enlisted and civilians the
mission was to educate the public in
Congress about the Army Reserves because
people when they think of they hear of
the reserves they think of the National
Guard they don't think of the Army
Reserve which has armories and they have
soldiers in every state in our Union but
people don't think about that okay so
when Desert Storm ended right and when
does her storm hit the army mobilized
both National Guard and Reserve units
okay
the National Guard had now full
transparency as I said I'm an Army
Reserve guy okay so I'm pretty jaded on
this you want to say that but you know
the National Guard has great Patriots
I'm not casting aspersions on them at
all you know but a facts are facts and
here's what happened when when does the
storm hit the National Guard has three
so-called premier infantry brigades that
were supposed to round out
active duty divisions okay one of them
was the 48th otter Georgia okay
and there was an National Guard Brigade
that in upon mobilization they would be
assigned to that division and they would
go to war with the division okay and
what happened was when it came and by
the way they had all the best equipment
they had better equipment than some
active army battalions and brigades they
had Abrams tanks you have to understand
this is the early 90s they had Abrams
tanks and they had Bradley vehicles when
a lot of active units didn't have that
okay but they were publicized as being
the premier Army National Guard combat
units that were ready to go to war okay
when the balloon went up the army said
we can't send these guys they're just
gonna be cannon fodder so they sent them
to the NTC the National Training Center
in California for 90 days okay only
problem was the war ended so quick they
never got to they never got there mm-hmm
all right the reserves on the other hand
our soldiers performed magnificently we
had helicopter units we had medical
units we had Civil Affairs we had psyops
we you know our people did extremely my
training division perfect example you
know we were mobilized I had my guys in
the front gates of Fort Benning within
72 hours and my drill instructors around
the trail my my-my-my instructors are on
the platform teaching you know running
the ranges and all that and so then when
it came time to downsize is that where
you took a stand yeah absolutely what
happened was that you know when the we
show a window desert storm and then the
Soviet Union falls apart and the wall
comes down right so everybody's looking
for this piece of unit to transfer money
from the Defense Department to social
services
okay and so the Army has a process
that's called the total army analysis
it's a very good logical process so you
can determine the force structure that
we need for the army okay and the way it
works is you look at what are the what
are we facing throughout the world you
know whether the problem area is you
know and then you save yourself okay
based on that how many divisions do
infantry divisions do we need how many
armored units how many helicopter
battalion you know blah blah blah and
then you face reality and you say how
much money can we really get out of
Congress for this so based on all that
stuff you come up with a force structure
okay the army didn't do that what they
did is they had the vice chief of staff
of the army the Chief of Army Reserves
the chief of the National Guard Bureau
the president of the National Guard
Association which is not a government
and the president of the Reserve
Officers Association go to a hotel and
they cut a deal and it was called the
off-site agreement because it wasn't
done at the Pentagon okay well I told
you I had formed this Army Reserve
Association mm-hmm right I had people in
that meeting within five minutes I knew
what happened and the Army Reserves
really they they eliminated eighty
percent of Army Reserve aviation and we
had for Special Forces groups at that
time in the reserve components there
were two National Guard groups the 19th
and 20th and two Army Reserve Special
Forces groups the eleventh and the
twelfth the twelfth of the zone was when
the units that I was under my command
and I was the deputy commanding general
of an army reserve unit so I'll give you
an example we had a Blackhawk battalion
once again in my army reserve under my
command that fought in the Gulf they
were so good that Schwarzkopf selected
them for his taxi unit okay and they had
received the it's called the army
aviation Association award triple-a
award for the best Blackhawk battalion
so that's how good these guys were okay
this Agreement eliminated that unit out
of the Army Reserves and put it into the
Illinois National Guard okay now I'm a
big boy I I can I can except I don't
appreciate it as a taxpayer but I can
accept waste of money or whatever where
I draw the line in the sand is when you
jeopardize soldiers lives and the
readiness of our forces okay this unit
overnight Oh what I didn't tell you was
the Illinois National Guard did not have
one qualified Blackhawk pilot or
mechanic they could not even fly those
birds from Scott Air Force Base where we
had them to the Illinois National Guard
field they had to go to the Wisconsin
and Minnesota Guard to borrow pilots so
they could move those birds now the
implication is that unit overnight went
from c1 you know the highest readiness
rating down the c5 which is non non
deployable
basically you know and it it took about
three years plus to get that unit up to
C 3 which is just marginal deployment
level okay so that's one example another
example are those Special Forces groups
okay the army looked at the four Reserve
Component Special Forces groups and they
said you know we only need two okay so
we'll eliminate the National Guard you
know groups because you know why does
the National Guard govern why does the
governor
you know Farsi speaking demolitions
expert okay in the last time I looked we
didn't have an insurgency in Illinois so
so the National Guard says no we don't
accept that so the Army with their tail
between their legs go back to the
drawing board
and they looked at readiness which is
what they probably should have done to
begin with and they found out that the
12th group in the USA in the Army
Reserves was the best out of the four
and then it was either I think it was
the 20th out of the guard was the second
best so they said okay we got the
solution
we'll take one out of each component
right guard wouldn't accept that so what
did they do they eliminated both Army
Reserve you know you know groups and I
was livid because the 12th was under me
at one time I wasn't the commander of it
but it was in my chain we had taken that
unit from c4 to c2 which for a reserve
unit to be able to get reservists to
pass those special forces qualifications
that's not easy okay and they eliminated
that unit now I'm a big boy okay when it
came to like to the the helicopter units
and I said okay take my pilot's and so
in and mechanics take the reserve patch
off their shoulder make them National
Guardsmen I'm good with it
okay they wouldn't do it because it was
jobs for the guard so my guys had to
find new jobs some of them had to
actually change I Miles's because you
know there were no no aviation jobs for
them right and just thank you you and I
it's taxpayers how much that cost us you
know so so now I'm getting all kinds of
calls from the field you know we didn't
have computers at that time in the
internet so I get telephone calls and
faxes saying general somebody's got to
stand up and fight this you know in that
meeting I told
you about that they had I found out from
my moles that in essence they were gonna
have a press conference the next day
where everybody was gonna hold hands and
sing Kumbaya and say that the Army has
come up with this great agreement where
everybody agrees and nobody disagrees
well that wasn't true mmm-hmm a lot of
people disagreed with it so I called the
vice chief of staff's office at the
Pentagon right not as Major General Jim
ooyama but as Jim Okayama president Army
Reserve Association okay so I call
asking for a return call about this this
press conference it's gonna happen our
announcement you know and I didn't get a
call back so the next morning an hour
before their press conference we sent
out a press release and we basically
said this is not good this is you know
shouldn't go through need to have a GAO
study of Government Accounting Office
study and that pretty well got me into
the crosshairs and so then what we did
is and now keep in mind I had never done
this in my life I never lobbied I had
never been to Congress I had never
walked the halls you know any of that
stuff we had a way actually and I think
I might have sent you some of this stuff
but we had a meeting of the Army Reserve
Association called for it in Washington
DC and I had men and women come from all
over the country and we went and we
lobbied our senators and congressmen and
we told them this is wrong this needs
that there needs to be a Jo state needs
to be studied right before it's
implemented okay now frankly I knew we
were talking at windmills but I had to
do it because you know all I was getting
all these requests from sergeants and
civilians and lieutenant
and majors throughout the country saying
somebody's gotta fight this and they
were right so I had to do it some then I
get an invitation from a Congressional
subcommittee okay it was not a subpoena
so I didn't have to go I could have said
I've got a headache or I've got a
conflict or whatever but I didn't you
know I said yeah I'll be there and I
went and I testified and a year later I
was history shall we say but it's like I
said Jocko I I wouldn't hesitate in a
moment to do it again it's when I was in
Vietnam I knew that our generals are not
standing up for us all the time like
they should and I said never get to a
point in life or it's the difference
between my career and and my soldiers
the soldiers win yeah absolutely and
that's one of those balance things too
is you know as leader when do you know
you you want to toe the line and I have
people ask me this pretty regularly well
you know you always say you want to
support the chain of command but what if
the chain of command is wrong no it's
real simple answer if the chain of
command is wrong and it's something that
matters like the safety of your troops
the training of your troops then you
stand up to it you know if it's
something that doesn't matter for they
go oh we want you to fill out this
paperwork differently than you did it
yesterday you know what I do I do it
right I don't care you know you want me
to put my uniform on this way instead of
that way that's fine whatever I'll do it
you want to start putting soldiers of
jeopardy that won't that won't stand so
here's what happened okay well all this
stuff is going on the Washington Post
puts this front page okay and it talks
about how the the big controversy you
know in my associations right at the
forefront of all the so I'm quoted and
all those now keep them on I'm still an
active Army Reserve Major General and
great honor right and and in fact before
I testified I got a call from the chief
of staff at TRADOC who's a good friend
of mine we were both major journals and
and he didn't tell me I shouldn't go he
kind of said that well you know it's
really not a good idea you know for you
to go and he was a good friend of mine
and I said John you know I I understand
this is you have to do this this is your
you know this is your job but I gotta go
I can't I cannot stand by and let this
pass so he under well and and so that
was also in the Washington Post you know
like I was threatened I wasn't
threatened you know and so so basically
I then the Army Times wrote an editorial
which basically criticized the Army
Reserves especially in my association
you know in and saying the army reserves
are not team players they're crybabies
you know and but what got me is when
they said they're putting out bad
information
okay that was in their editorial okay so
I wrote an op-ed okay which to their
credit they published him and in the
op-ed I said number one
where is and the title of their their
editorial was the enemy is us okay
mmm-hmm and I said I agree with you
the enemy is us but the problem is
number one where is you didn't list in
detail the false information that was
being put out by the reserves so you
need to do that I said that in the op-ed
they never did by the way because we had
never put out anything false but the
second thing I said and I said if we go
to war in the next 18 months and this
thing goes through we're gonna have
people coming back in body bags that
would not have I mean now that's a
pretty serious statement is indeed okay
and you would think if I was chicken
little saying the sky was falling that
they would have been inundated with
letters from the field say
the generals gone too far right they
didn't get one letter and so but so
because of the stand I took needless to
say the army wasn't real happy with me
and a year later when it came time to to
get a new assignment surprise surprise I
was not considered there were no
assignments that I was considered
eligible for and so I I said this been
fun
so the Chief of Army Reserve actually
wanted me to stay and he said this too
shall pass so why don't you stay you can
go into a control group which is kind of
this administrative pool of people who
don't have assignments and maybe in a
year or two you can come back you know
we'll get you an assignment
and I said no I said you know the Army's
made it very clear you know they don't
want my services they don't think I have
any value and I'm gonna move on I'm
gonna move on in life mm-hmm ya know so
what I did now even though you moved on
you retired you didn't stop serving by
any stretch and and you know I look at
the military outreach that you started
is really your new way of serving it was
that is that an accurate statement oh
absolutely
what what happened was you know my wife
is so wonderful she's she said she's not
as as Christian as I am but she lives
her life better than I do
and so I'm having my personal pity party
feeling sorry for myself because my 32
year career is down the toilet right and
she said Jim you know God is sending you
a message number one that you know this
chapter in your life is over
okay number two you survived Vietnam you
also became attain the rank of two-star
general which was the highest and
reservist could get at that time okay
and then she says number three and you
got me as a wife
how can I argue with that right but she
was absolutely right what happened was
God brought other things into my life at
that time Promise Keepers which is a
men's Christian group I got involved
with a church in Chicago a Willow Creek
Community Church which was a very famous
evangelical church I I led a men's small
group I lead a men's monthly breakfast I
got involved with the Department of
Veterans Affairs which I had never been
involved in before at a national level
and I was the chairman of an advisory
committee on minority veterans and I was
I was on that for five years so I
learned about the VA system all of this
was in preparation for me to eventually
start military outreach USA about seven
years ago which is a non-profit
faith-based organization for the very
simple concept Jocko we're trying to
develop a national network of partners
mostly houses of worship of all faiths
by the way and organizations like the
VFW American Legion Rotary clubs Lions
Clubs high schools this is all at the
local community level that will reach
out to our military community which we
defined by the way as active duty
reserves National Guard veterans of all
eras and their family members we
stressed the family members equally
because they serve and sacrifice as well
okay and to reach out to them to be a
welcoming environment to appreciate
their service recognize that and to
offer hope and help if they need it now
the churches and synagogues want to help
they don't know how to do it because
they don't understand the military
culture they don't know the issues that
our military community is facing and
they don't know where the resources are
that's where military outreach USA comes
in we provide all of that information we
have webinars we have publications we
have DVDs we have presentations and
everything that we do is free of charge
no cost the only thing we ask is when
people join us as partners either as a
house of worship or as an organization
that they commit to take our materials
and use them to help our military
community and it doesn't cost them
anything and if people want to want to
help out military outreach USA no the
website is military outreach usa.org
that's correct and then from there what
what are you looking for well we have
numerous programs because we understand
houses of worship come in all shapes and
sizes okay so we have different programs
that they can choose from some are as
simple as a church can list the names of
service members who are currently
serving you know either relatives or or
members of the church and people can
pray for them prayer is so important
when you're overseas especially in a
combat situation I know it helped me a
lot when I was in combat I need it all I
could get I'll tell you but also they
could do things like send packages son
letters help today who writes letters
nobody you know it's all email and all
that stuff how about getting a letter
right at mail call how neat is that you
know but then we can also do things for
veterans in fact we we have two years
ago we started a program and by the way
we have a memorandum of agreement that
was signed by the Department of Veterans
Affairs in 2016 by the secretary himself
which recognized military outreach USA
as a national partner with them on a
program that we
initiated called veterans exiting
homelessness okay
now here's the thing the VA has done a
very good job in reducing the veteran
homeless population it's still too high
but it's three years agos like a hundred
and fifty thousand oh you know it's like
fifty thousand no which is still too
high but look at the look at the
reduction okay well that's created a new
problem and the problem is when they
take a homeless veteran male or female
some with kids off the street and they
work with a caseworker or a social
worker okay and the social worker feels
that they're stabilized and now they can
get them to what so is called permanent
housing which is really an apartment
that's God that's subsidized by a HUD
Vash voucher okay they give them the
keys to the apartment right but homeless
people that's all they give them so just
think it the first time you moved into
an apartment you need stuff Lysol toilet
paper buckets sponges mops you know
dishes how about a bed homeless people
they get a one-bedroom apartment but
guess what they don't have a bet right
so we came up with this program called
moving essentials and we listed things
like we have a bathroom kit we have a
kitchen kit we even have a beds for vets
program nurse okay and what we've done
is we've gone out to our our our
churches our partners you know
organizations and we've asked them can
you conduct a donation drive of this
stuff okay I'm not asking them collect
money give me the stuff okay and then
it's delivered to the VA Medical Center
social worker and they distribute it to
the veterans so we know they're going to
veterans okay because you know there are
a lot of people out there cleaning to be
veterans who are not and so we know
they're going to veterans and it goes
out almost as quick as it comes in okay
this has helped us a great
deal as an organization because before
we're at a point in time where we really
can move up to the next level as an
organization but we frankly need
volunteers and money okay because we
don't have a stamp we've done all this
on a shoestring basically and so with
this program we now have results that we
can show people okay so if people come
to me and say Jim you know what
difference are you guys making two years
ago all I could say was while we're
developing this network of partners and
we're asking none to help you know in
their communities which did make a
difference by the way I mean we
prevented some suicides we've helped
people that needed stuff you know but we
didn't have I mean I don't have the
staff to record all of this stuff you
know but when we came up with this
program we have a tracking thing where
we know how many veterans are being
helped we know what's been collected and
we know so now if somebody says what
difference do you make okay since
January of 2016 we have helped over
31,000 veterans we've collected over
750,000 items in fact I think it's over
a million though and valued at almost
two million dollars and we have probably
just provided this month our 1000th bed
okay and so now I've got stuff that I
can tell people this well we've come up
with the new program this year and it's
called adopt a caregiver okay see what
we're trying to do is find find gaps
where there's a need and nobody else is
filling it so we first we did that
veterans exiting homelessness thing well
now there are 5.5 million military
caregivers in our country
okay serving over 1.1 million mill
former military okay and they get some
help from the VA but not a lot as much
as they need okay so we are now going to
our churches and our organizations and
we're saying we have this program adopt
a caregiver okay and if you want to be a
caregiver you let us know and we'll
contact the local social worker and
volunteer support at the VA facility
near you and we'll hook you up with a
caregiver that needs help now this could
be anything could be babysitting could
be mowing a lawn it could be shoveling
snow it could be showing up with a meal
it could be just showing up and being
there for three hours and let the
caregiver get a break okay this is not
rocket scientist stuff it's an easy
program but it's something that if we
can get this moving like we did the
veterans exiting homelessness it's gonna
be a tremendous help for our veterans
and but most importantly for the
caregivers you see I and another
lifetime my wife and I were hospice
patient volunteers we did that for six
years so I know how it is to deal with
terminal illness okay but I also
witnessed that it's the caregivers who
are sometimes need to help more than the
patient you know and so in this case
we've got military caregivers that need
help and we can do it through this
program well it sounds like like I said
you're continuing to serve even though
you're no longer in uniform and I think
that's probably a pretty good place to
wrap up for today and you know again
it's been just an absolute honor to sit
down and talk with you as we get
feedback from this episode I
we'll come to Chicago and go to your
museum and and we'll do this again yeah
let me say one thing I was not able to
get in and anybody who knows me would
tell me Jim why didn't you say that I
have a standard mantra okay and that is
every day is a great day I have my faith
my family and live in the finest country
in the world I see it every day every
chance I got
and people ask me well why you know how
can you be so positive and you know why
do you say that I say well number one as
a very young 24 year old company
commander in Vietnam in combat there
were times I didn't know if I was going
to be alive the next moment much less
see the next sunrise when you're in
those circumstances what is important in
life becomes real focused and that is
faith family and living in the finest
country in the world now so then people
will come back at me and say well how
can you say that when we have so much
division in our country okay and I say
listen I'm a little bit longer into thin
you are and when I was a kid
the I've seen the improvements in our
society when it comes to race relations
know I'm a minority so I get it and I
told him the the odds of me becoming
when I was a kid the odds of me becoming
a Major General in the United States
Army were slim and next to none okay
when you know when we've had an
african-american president who was
reelected and then I tell people when
President Kennedy was elected that was a
big deal and and a lot of people don't
know why and I say because he was
Catholic but today that's that's that's
not a big deal right and that that
though in those days that was a big deal
so I tell people every day is a great
day I have my faith my family we live in
the finest country in the world
well that saying was challenged about
five-and-a-half years ago when I had
some health challenges which I think I
didn't mention it earlier today are you
ever I was still working
financial services industry and I got up
in the morning or shaving and I felt
this pain in my chest and I mean it
wasn't a serious pounding and I wasn't
sweating nausea I didn't have a
temperature so I thought of something I
ate you know give it five minutes it'll
go away right it didn't go away so I
told my wife this is not good so I
finished shaving and dressing though and
she drove me to the emergency room of
the hospital so I walk in and I say hey
you know I've got this pain in my chest
I don't know what it is so they do an
EKG and they said you have had a heart
attack
well suddenly all these doctors and
nurses swooped in to the ER they
undressed me and they put me in a
hospital gown I'm on a gurney and I'm on
my way to the operating room right so
I'm in the corridor and on this gurney
and I say to myself self can you say
today is a great day and I said I
absolutely can I survive Vietnam I have
a wonderful wife and children and I most
importantly have my faith so in 24 hours
I had three operations the first
operation was for the heart attack okay
so they do an angiogram they found out
my LD which is the Widowmaker artery was
90 percent block so they do an
angioplasty put a stent in
so by 10 o'clock in the morning I'm in
the recovery room so I'm thinking well
that's that's the end of it right that
wasn't the end of it the second thing
that happened was my heart cavity
started to fill up with liquid it's
called a fusion so I had to go back in
for and they had to put a hole in my
chest so they could put a tube there so
they could drain this liquid and it
filled up a bottle it took about 24
hours to do that okay the third thing
that happened then was my kidneys failed
so I had to go back in and they had to
put another hole in my chest so they
could hook up a date dialysis machine
okay
so the standard procedure every
time I was rolled into the operating
room is what's your name what's your
birthday how do you feel okay so I'm on
the operating table and I say Jim
Oklahoma August 3rd 44 every day is a
great day I have my faith my family and
live in the finest country in the world
I can't tell you the effect that had on
the doctors and nurses the first
operation the doctor said what is your
faith and I said well since you asked me
doc I said I'm a Christian Christ is my
Savior you're skilled physician skilled
nurses but I'm in God's hands so
whatever he decides I'm okay with so
let's get on with it so the second
operation there was a nurse and she said
where do you go to church and I said
well I attend Willow Creek Community
Church and she said I do too so no
coincidence the third operation this was
the coolest thing there was a male nurse
who was wearing a camouflage gown and I
said you must have been in the army Nick
I said yeah I was a medic and I said
well hey I just want you to know I
retired as a two-star general so take
good care of me
will you and so that was kind of my my
testing of all that now the final thing
I tell you which was a god thing
months later I was going I had to go
through dialysis okay so I'm going
through this dialysis and and three
months later I get a donor and the donor
was our daughter okay but our daughter
is not our biological daughter we
adopted her 30-something years ago and
yet she was a match so guys when I say
every day is a great day I have my faith
my family and live in the kind of finest
country in the world I can truly say
that and every day every day is an
encouragement to me okay today was an
encouragement this morning when I was
honored to participate in the National
Day of Prayer with the 79th the
theater Sustainment Command at Los
Alamitos and this podcast is an
encouragement to me so I just want you
to know that and remember every day is a
great day
faith family we live in the finest
country in the world well sir
even though this is my podcast and I'm
supposed to talk after that I don't
really have anything else to say thank
you so much for coming on it's been a
complete honor to have you and I look
forward to doing this again at some
point in the future thank you so much
and the general has left the building
and we have actually relocated back to
our recording studio and just amazing
opportunity and definitely thanks to
thanks to Jay Fukuyama for connecting us
and send a little gift to you as well so
thanks for thanks for putting this
together with your dad and echo yes
speaking of putting things together
yes yeah if somebody wanted to put
together something for themselves and
maybe something that would you know
support yeah yeah yeah could you brief
us on those things namely your joints
you want to keep those together mm-hmm
cuz it's a big deal if they're not
together so good news if you didn't all
right already even though you didn't
already chock my supplements they're
called Jaco super krill its krill oil
but that's not in the name technically
also chuckle joint or fair also for your
joints obviously take both um there's
some anti-inflammatory stuff in there
too by the way something that I might
have mentioned before anyway three
joints very good very important
subscribe for the the recurring delivery
oh yeah cuz you don't want to run out
I'm telling you it's jump when you're
right now I've run out before its whack
also discipline supplement called
discipline it is a pre-workout
pre-mission pre-study pre take test pre
cognitive enhancing supplements good
this is a good one
pree get after it and it tastes good
interestingly enough jakka focused a lot
on that tastes good lemon-lime etc etc
many calories in this one I don't know
not very many 30 all right there you go
so you can do it while you fast -
technically depends on your metabolic
response look and do it before you fast
I can make any claims nonetheless it's a
good one for your brain for your body
good supplement also yeah so mulk
protein powder do you are you are we
even calling it protein powder or we're
just calling it straight-up mole no it's
not it's more within watts yeah so that
is chocolate chip no mint chocolate
chips yeah yeah so if you don't like
mint chocolate chip
you might there's a chance you might not
like this if you do like mint chocolate
chip there's a real good cheese really
like I would say around 100 percent
probability you're gonna like this one I
should clarify that mmm I mix it
primarily with milk me too
I have mixed it also plain with well not
playing but with cold water
yeah it's with milk it's straight-up
delicious yeah straight up it's a
milkshake you like oh I don't what what
do I truly in the world want to have for
dessert I want to have more right with
water it's more like a ham sandwich sir
you know okay hey this thing is good I
you know I need some fuel you don't you
don't get all fired up when you have a
ham sandwich right yeah you know you
know you're not reaching the next level
yeah you're happy you're not fired up
yeah yeah that's kind of what milk with
water is like a ham sandwich it's better
for you but yeah taste taste reaction is
about the same for me ham sandwich yeah
yeah the small with with milk so it's
it's legit what is it like a what like a
state states vaguely yeah comparative
hang that's all fired a few boom
chuckles review on law well no actually
no it's not it's like am in shock
milkshake that's what it's like yeah
because the steak is a different thing
for me yeah steak is a little bit of a
different experience that's a really
good experience so technically you can't
a guy can't replace take no no but if
you the last fast I did you know and I
posted that picture and I wouldn't got
that I wouldn't got a killer steak yeah
any I nothing was so good cuz he did
after the fact so good yes we got a
hundred percent of the taste 100% of the
taste yeah no more than other percent
the country Tempe yeah somebody sent me
some tomahawk steaks yeah to my house
mm-hmm and they came with instructions
from the company that sent him on how to
cook him and I'll I don't remember the
name of the company right now I followed
those instructions I cooked those steaks
those things were epic yeah they were
epic yeah so interesting yeah no steaks
came to my house or anything like that
or next to mine but hey they do some
good and they some even better after cuz
currently we're getting our fast on yes
currently officially - yeah yeah what do
we already know um well I you I'm at 23
hours or something and I think I'm at
like 18 right now what's good you eat at
11 o'clock last night yeah you got
issues why because like I don't really
start eating till like later in the day
breakfast like that you see them though
let's say eat three meals a day and
that's not a lot but uh yeah that's
actually a little bit you know some
kinds do you know that could not like
that guy three times a day sometimes -
so let's say I ate my first meal no
breakfast only water maybe some coffee
sometimes maybe some Gatorade something
maybe like a banana sometimes not a lot
nonetheless at noon ish one maybe to
lunch dinner ate like six boom and then
again at 11:00 that's more that's not
that much yeah okay do you want to do
over there nonetheless I'm at about 18
hours you give or take and that's take
day you're just talking about the Tom
Ocwen sounds real yeah
but ya better come real fired up because
I think right now real fired up by the
way you didn't even mention where you
can get all this good stuff
well there's even more good stuff so I
what I what I'd like to do is like get
us really excited about everything and
then it's like dang where can you get it
oh I do want to say we have in the
testing phase right now
chocolate peanut butter
Molk Molk now everyone's probably
wondering hey what's up what's up with
just chocolate malt yeah we for whatever
reason I don't know if it's the
complementary of flavors but we haven't
been able to nail the chocolate flavor
the way we want it at this time yeah
yeah the the mint I don't know you know
the mint is awesome yeah the chocolate
peanut butter epic yeah we haven't
nailed the chocolate yet we got vanilla
the vanilla's I'm not a vanilla fan yeah
but the vanilla is good I can't I can't
give it 9 stars because I I can't give 9
stars to things that I don't personally
really love the taste of because I don't
love vanilla I'll try it again once it
once we roll out with the actual live
vanilla milk but the chocolate milk will
come when we get it right but the peanut
butter milk
stand by to get south yeah isn't that
the whole kind of defining factor of the
vanilla flavor it's like it's not
supposed to be amazing it's supposed to
be vanilla like people use the word
vanilla no this guy let me do a great
thing let me tell you I actually let me
tell you when when when I do absolutely
love vanilla flavor you know when you go
to a restaurant and you're like alright
tonight we're gonna get some and use an
order dessert and you get some kind of a
chocolate scenario lately let's say
let's just let's just talk about a
chocolate that's hot chocolate brownie
right yeah you roll up one of those so
there's a my my local one of my local
restaurants they have a dessert mm-hmm
they call it the E legal mmm because
it's so good it should be illegal yeah
this is Ragland
sure Ragueneau be and what it is they
take a cast iron
skillett you know and they put chocolate
chip cookie in there and then and I when
they make it for us we don't we get it
once every two months we'll go illegal
time and that was an extra ice cream
because you need it because it's got
that chocolate it's hot they are so good
and you know what I just realized we're
on the 24-hour fasting kind of longer
kind of don't mind it and you're right
about that vanilla thing too by the way
because people do well people do use the
word vanilla and vanilla to describe
room you love the Royal just yes just
vanilla which is you know it's not great
but it's not junk its cast iron skillet
you're 100% right that's especially when
you said when you go to restaurants I
probably know where you learned this and
you're absolutely right so that being
said so what do you do then you put some
chocolate like Hershey syrup in the
vanilla milk that's a violation oh no
there'd be a big fight that just sounds
real good right now I'm just the legal
it should be illegal for us to do see
I've been on I've been fasting before
and down the podcast but this is
different when I know that you're yeah
the same boat and this is kind of like
uh usually I'm just cruising at home
like I've done it before for sure
my name is Kru there's home and it's
like boom yeah but now like yeah once
you get to talking about it shoot then
and I got a drive by windy either way
you get all this stuff vanilla monk not
right now uh chocolate peanut butter I'm
open all right now chocolate mint
yes mint chocolate right now right now
we're going origin main dot-com that's
where you get it boom and all the other
super krill that that is like everyday
stuff you could take that one everyday
get on the subscription thing but these
you know all this other stuff after all
of it like I said all of it or Jemaine
calm also at origin main I'll tell you
what there's on there is G's produ Jitsu
very important when you start jiu-jitsu
or if you already started you just you
need Agee people still ask good and I'm
glad they do because I not the answer
form what ye do I
I started used to what he do I get
sometimes I ask the color and that's a
whole different question but they say
what brand of key here's the brand
origin brand 100% made in America best
these are the keys that like Pete and
all that one they make them they take
into consideration all the movements of
jiu-jitsu like everything even down to
this and think about we might not even
have thought about it like outside of
when you put this on okay so in a
regular key they have the string to tie
on the pants not the belt the string on
the pants then you have a belt that goes
over the the D top all that stuff
no that's string fine we're used to it
and fine that's a cool string but you
ever like put in the dryer where it got
caught on something or whatever and that
string gets lost in the little tooth I
don't even see it I'm saying right yeah
good project hoodie that'll happen to
your hoodie and you gotta get the hanger
and you got to do this big thing if you
even know how otherwise I kind of
screwed in a way cuz you got to go all
up in there now take the origin gay
these are just these details that when
you get someone who's thinking of this
kind of stuff when they design the whole
gay you got some key there that this is
one of the many reasons why you get the
origin key this one the string comes out
that's okay because it's not this this
endless black hole loop holder don't you
Simms in yeah it's like it'll have like
it's a giant thick wide belt loops yeah
and a bunch of you too
so you have like you know it's it's so
easy to put them in that's even if you
even want the string if you don't the
string you're like hey I'm over strings
I don't like tying my string they give
you this little bell you'll see if you
have origin get you're like you're
exactly exactly for walk yeah yeah it's
a teeny it's a thin belt that goes
through and click you click the belt
make it tight or whatever it's like a
little mini bill you don't you don't
feel it when you're rolling nothing like
that did you think you're gonna feel it
when you rolled it was a question there
was a question of you I found I'm you
know this seems kind of weird yeah and
then you put it on you don't you don't
notice it all no no it's until it comes
time to take it off on it so easy yeah
boom again it's like we probably never
really thought of this until you
actually do it like I can when you're
when you're done Danny you don't really
think about it but it's just one of
those things and more sicknesses these
are good yeah
he's one of the many details yeah
included I was talking to a guy
yesterday I was getting interviewed and
I said yeah well you know I he's asked
me about all my different businesses
right whatever that means all of you
yeah yeah and I said well you know I
have a apparel company and we make we
make apparel up in Maine got a big
factory up in Maine he says oh Maine
that's up in Maine a factory in Maine
and you know I was like yeah and he was
all surprised and I said you know what
it's sad that you're surprised at that
because 50 years ago everybody knew that
that's where they made stuff they made
it up there and it all disappeared and
now it's coming back and we're bringing
it back I told this guy I said we're
bringing it back we're bringing back
manufacturer we got we're weaving
material up there you don't know what
you don't even know what I'm talking
about
people's first instinct it's like oh if
you want material you got to go to
overseas and you got to have you got to
get it get it made in some sweatshop
somewhere that's that's that's accepted
right that's accepted like oh you just
you know hey you can't beat those prices
and you can't you can't overcome the the
tariffs and whatever else no you know
what yes you can
yeah yes you can't and we are we're
doing it yeah you get the cotton in like
North Carolina you're screwheads his own
South Carolina I'm screwing it up to get
in America one of the current know that
yeah in America the thing is that just
talk to Peter I'm pretty sure he said
North could've been so I don't know
mm-hm I forget apologize nonetheless it
is in America just like you said and
then they bring it up and here's what it
is - the secret they have their looms
they have their own looms you can't just
walk into a store and start buying looms
you just can't do that that's why it's
hard to you know to kind of that's why
they have a unique situation there it's
all made in America everyone that is
supporting us at origin thank you
because right now you know what we're
doing we're expanding
we're buying more machines we're buying
better equipment and we're hiring more
people so thank you for your support
it's awesome we're only able to bring
manufacturing back to America because of
you knowing that you want to have the
best and you want to made America so
thanks everyone
yeah
you fucking that much appreciate it yeah
that's the one
origin main dot-com a lot of cool stuff
on there some hoodies not to mention the
most comfortable pants in the world
officially now officially I'm wearing
right now we go to LA today good fine
you know whatever but you're gonna want
to wear something comfortable this is my
thought process before we went nowhere
the most comfortable thing that I own
straight up no question me origin pants
boom
anyway also like I said keys rash guards
compression gear and whatnot anyway just
go there or gin mancom get what you want
also the immersion camps jujitsu camp
jujitsu immersion camp not concentration
camp not not necessarily summer camp not
band camp not band camp no it's like
it's emerging can immerse yourself in
jujitsu you train as much or as little
as you want but you get to be in
jiu-jitsu the whole time boom one week
two sessions you can do both if you want
by the way Chuck will be there I will be
there but maybe not at full capacity the
jury's still out it now we're gonna see
about some stuff
long story Dave Burke Lafe looks like
make sure you go
JP working it anyway a lot of fun people
will be there it's gonna be a good good
time um if last year is any indicator
Samir real good time also if you want to
vary up your workout you want to get
some kettlebells like some someone just
texted me today well you know DM what
wait kettlebells should I use okay
here's the thing that's a broad question
that's a real bit so who are you exactly
right yeah it's no actually it's an easy
answer I didn't order the 48 kilogram
ones yeah potentially kill yourself or
some smashing in your toe cuz you can't
hold it or it's too light for you I
don't know it just depends so depends on
how much you know about using
kettlebells depends on how strong you
are depends on how big you are and it
depends on what kind of yeah well it
does know it depends on what kind of
fitness you're trying to achieve yeah
yes trying to get big and strong you
want to get a bigger crowd about yeah if
you're trying to get
more metcon conditioning and whatnot
then you get maybe a smaller credible
yeah the last point is hey
it depends depends but here's the thing
I will say this and say this with
complete bias because I'm on it kettle
puff on it those are the kettle bells
you get regardless of what size you get
the artsy primal bell ones that's in
this one you get they're just way cooler
also if you want to vary up we work out
like I said no boring workouts chocolate
doesn't have boring workouts apparently
I thought he did he doesn't I know but
you want to make your workouts
interesting different movements
functional strength and actual strength
there's other stuff on there starting
with like it's a spectrum it goes from
jump ropes all the way up to but mate
steel bells
what's a steel bell they look like a
frisbee right but there's filled with
metal but what do you do with them see
there that's the point so there's a
bunch of stuff on there anyway a lot of
good stuff Letta what did I just get
there pretty cool all the socks boom on
it socks on it's off straight up yeah
there's a lot of lot of cool stuff on
there on there a lot of good information
on there too so a lot of the questions
that are directed at me I don't know the
answer I sometimes I know the answer for
me as a buys me some stuff I heard but
it's real flimsy a lot of time you're
gonna hunted a lot of information on
there so get some as they say on it calm
slash chuckles good way to support if
you want something get something also
when you get these books that chocolate
reviews sometimes hack Earth's books
about face good one
steel my soldiers hearts good on any of
the books feel the need to get one hate
to wear it organize all the books by
episode choco podcast comical choco
podcast calm click on the top books from
episodes boom I gotta organize perfectly
click through there get your book get
whatever book you wanna get two books
gonna leave lurk just continue should
just go just do your amazon thing and
you're all good good way to support also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already on itunes stitcher
google play podcast pod bean pod this
podcast apps out there just subscribe to
the podcast what I'm saying
that's kind of the thing regards to what
podcasts application you're using it's
good way to support the review if you're
in the mood just leave a review
you know when you kind of think about if
you're not in the mood to leave a review
I don't even know if it's conducive to
leave a review or interesting I don't
know I said go for it yes you go for a
bt f PG a-- right i say if you in the
mood lee review you also we have youtube
channel if you didn't know already to
subscribe to that and that's a good way
to support as well we have excerpts on
there try to post every day try to
sometimes two a day try to also on there
is enhanced excerpts I know what you
mean by you mean you put some
cinematography into the scenario you
film and then you edit with music and
other special effects CGI and what not
sure well at the very least I'll put
some music on there you know things are
exploding you redid the warpath video so
there's no longer horrible Christmas
horrible see I put Christmas music on
that cuz it's Christmas time yeah you
want to get Christmas spirit watch the
watch the Christmas 1914 video that's a
good one as well and that's better
Christmas spirit is real to Christmas
yeah nonetheless that's why I did it but
look you make a good point it was in our
favorites never put Christmas music in
one of my what do they call excerpts oh
now that yours okay I'm in it alright
don't put Christmas music in our
excerpts right you got it
I promise otherwise a year exer actually
alright hey I dig it and you know so
it's not gonna be Christmas every day a
wise man once said it's not Christmas
every day so why put Christmas music on
something that someone might may or may
not listen to every day so I understand
so yeah or you did you know revamp some
stuff sometimes
fYI my wife completely stuck up for you
on that one
yeah cuz yeah it's nice Christmas music
it was really that Christmas time
okay I just wanted to like hiding yeah
he's kind of a bummer too because that
was a really I know you put a lot of
time and effort into that video took a
little and so that so that when you
showed it to me
you were all excited and and the video
CGI stuff is awesome right
but hmm I know that you wanted me to be
just you know yeah over the top with
filled with awe at the video and I was
with the visuals but I was that was a
lot of that was countered by Christmas
songs and so what you saw from my
reaction was actually fake was fairly
fake there is a fair amount of realness
and I remember it now I won't forget it
cuz you're in cuz you know you go a
little bit inside where you all kind of
like form it where it does like a
certain thing and then it'll drop off
and they don't come back whatever so
there's this part where a certain part
start set up my call he's gonna he's
gonna kind of like that part right so
I'm kind of so I kind of look over at
you know super childish but I'm like
looking at you whatever and you're like
looking at it and then like one that
part he and it's Christmassy music
you're like so rough we change the
Christmas music as a result it'll boom
anyway I guess hit video of all time
yeah sure anyway yeah so yeah enhance
excerpts essence on there along with of
course the video version of this podcast
if you care the chocolate looks like
also choco is the store it's called
Yakko store URL is chocolate store calm
so website obviously I know but still
cool stuff on there and stuff is
creative I think so
go on their shirts hats we even got a
new hat it's like a flex fit now boom a
lot of people been asking for that
delivered gladly delivered anyway who
he's on there like I said rash guards
women's stuff some new mugs you know
what I think I'm put the tea on there so
if you know if they want to have that
option to get Jocko
tea and international you know oh yeah I
think you know just more options
we're convenient for the people you'd
call for everybody I think nonetheless a
lot of stuff on there uh if you want
something just get something also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album with tracks
choco tracks I know that sounds like
okay it's kind of esoteric chocolate
tracks what does that mean here this is
what it means it means it's not him
seeing nothing like that so in your mom
in your in your campaign against
weakness and we're all on the path
straight it's it's like common knowledge
really all of us were on the path like
if you're if we're listening to this
even me talking to you listen to me
we're on the path all of us one great
now this is inevitable I think for the
most part inevitable we're you know hit
moments of weakness sometimes you need a
little help through those moments of
weakness sometimes you need to just slip
in those moments of weakness and fall
and be like I'm not doing that again
sometimes that's useful you learn in my
opinion but in those moments of weakness
where you just need a little spot this
is what chocolate tracks are for so
let's say your weakness is not getting
up early you want to hit the snooze so
what you want to do to tired I don't
know whatever maybe drink a little bit I
don't know
so you're on the fence you're like I'm
gonna hit the snooze just for what was
what's at normal snooze ten minutes nine
minutes or whatever I don't know seem
sane do you have to tell me about that
actually it's not for the snooze
technically it's not for hitting the
snooze it's for going back to bed that's
the weakness that this particular track
because hitting the snooze like if you
just want to hit the snooze you're not
gonna have the energy to get up and you
know boom maybe if you put as your alarm
nonetheless is what it is the track it
it's jock on a specific track telling
you why you should just get up and not
hit the snooze or not stay in bed but
it's like jockle pragmatic advice it's
good 100% and this goes for uh diet
stuffs keeping workout stuff 100 percent
effectiveness 100% that's good speaking
of a hundred percent if you 100 percent
100% guaranteed want to be able to
deadlift 8000 pounds minimum you might
go over that all you have to do is drink
chocolate white tea it's that simple
bro okay dude am I gonna get sued for
false advertising
no because and here's why so this gate
Josiah this is named huge guy towards
bicep by the way few weeks ago maybe a
few months ago it's been probably a few
months unless big guy dead list you know
has the set up right and and he'll he'll
have videos there I watch him just
understand all we can and so he turns
his bicep you know it happens and so he
there's the video actually I think this
video was before you took tour the bicep
mm-hmm no no it was after so he has his
arm in a sling right bicep tear so he
drinks some chocolate white tea with the
ten pounds it and he smashes this in an
actual video smashes didn't throws of
the ten deadlifts one bad arm one hand
and it's like more than I can deadlift
for real in real life one hand deadlift
floor so boom proof proof simply a video
Josiah yeah there it is you can get that
on Amazon soon very soon
well I shouldn't say very soon within a
few weeks you're gonna be able to get
ready-made jockle white tea in a can
we're gonna put some companies out of
business
yeah cuz you're gonna be at 7-eleven
going oh you know what oh maybe I'll
have this sugar filled thing over here
and will make me feel like like a like
high on a sugar high for about fifteen
minutes and I want to I don't want to
fall asleep and be lame and I'll be
getting diabetes or I can have chocolate
cheese just cause that's coming that's
coming I'll let you all know and that's
out
hey books way the war your kid series
shows the path of hard work and
discipline to kids book to is out now
it's called marks mission teach your
kids to be stronger faster smarter more
confident teach them to have better
perspective on other people how to
handle verbal and physical bullying
yeah teaching view warrior kids and
speaking of more your kids if you want
to support a warrior kid go to Irish
Oaks ranch calm and get some or your
kids soap made by Aiden who's 13 years
old owns his own business chocolate so
yeah he makes chakra soap it's good to
use if you want to stay clean don't
forget about the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual and you know what
this is this is good
read read just read one section add a
legit read one section a day that will
legitimately keep you on the path try it
you're right yeah if you want to listen
to one track a day instead of read it
because maybe do it in the car or
whatever it's not on audible it's on mp3
the discipline calls freedom field
manual iTunes Amazon music google play
whatever you can listen to mp3s of
course there's the leadership book
extreme ownership combat leadership and
how to apply to your business in life
over a million copies of that have sold
that's a lot and it's not because we did
about big advertising campaign it's not
because we took out an advertisement in
the Super Bowl series no it's because of
word-of-mouth that's why people read it
cuz it works
so get that for your business in life
and actually if you want to now order
the follow-on book to extreme ownership
it's called the dichotomy of leadership
life and I just finished writing it
this book will it's really gonna help
leaders I can't wait to get it out there
into people's hands one of the hardest
things to do as leaders is to find the
balance between all the dichotomies of
leadership and this will help you do
that order it now otherwise the same
things going to happen publishers won't
have a copy for you near being mad and
I'll be mad that's the way it works if
you need direct leadership support for
your team contact national on front
which is my leadership consulting
company it's me it slave Babin it's JP
do now Dave Burke our website is echelon
front calm and we solve problems through
leadership that's what we do and of
course there's the muster leadership
seminar by the way
0:05 in Washington DC sold out so if you
want to come to muster you can't come to
that one you gotta wait until October
17th and 18th in San Francisco
California that is the next muster and
also at the muster we will not be
backstage in the green room clearing our
minds in an isolation float tank we will
not be doing tonight we will be with you
out there the whole time talking
answering questions working out eating
rolling jiu-jitsu everything come to the
muster pragmatic leadership training for
people that are leaders people that
aspire to be leaders and also on top of
that for current military law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
other first responders we have roll call
1 September 21st Dallas Texas it's one
day that's about leadership in dynamic
environments you can register to that
one as well at extreme ownership comm
and until we are together live at one of
those events whether it's the muster or
it's the roll call or it's the immersion
camp up in Maine if you want to
communicate with us you can do that via
the interwebs where we're cruising big
time I am Jacques I will link echo is at
Echo Charles and also military outreach
USA which is the organization that's run
by general Lu Yama if you want to follow
that they are on twitter at at Mill
outreach USA at Mill outreach USA they
also have their Facebook page which is
military outreach USA and if you didn't
catch the website the first time around
military outreach usa.org great
organization led by a great man General
James Mookie Yama and again we thank him
for his service sacrifice than what he
has done for our great nation and what
he
continues to do and I thank him for
coming on the podcast to share his
lessons learned and also thanks to his
son Jay for connecting us truly
appreciate it it was an amazing
experience for me to talk through
lessons learned that he learned from one
of my mentors and one of my heroes
colonel david hackworth so thank you
both and thanks to all the men and women
in uniform out there doing your duty
holding the line protecting our flag and
our freedom and to the police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics and
all the other first responders that
protect us day and night while we're
here at home thank you for your
vigilance and to everyone else that is
listening the factory factory workers
and drywall hangers and bankers and
brokers and waiters and waitresses and
cooks and dishwashers to business owners
and investors and software designers and
CEOs and salespeople to everyone out
there doing your best to do your best
think about those hardcore condos that
fought and think about those hardcore
condos that didn't come home remember
them and for them don't let up don't
slow down don't allow any slack and keep
getting after it so until next time this
is echo and Jocko